RIP.
Die zwei Sprechstunden.
Gezählt im Abendprogramm von Fritz am letzten Donnerstag im Monat und das bedeutet, eins, heute ist Chaos Radio. Also die zwei Stunden hier im Blue Moon, wo der Chaos Computer Club die Frequenz übernimmt und euch ein Thema seiner Wahl nahebringt. Mein Name ist Markus Richter, ich heiße euch herzlich willkommen zu diesem Chaos Radio in der 175. Ausgabe. Und zu Gast sind drei Leute aus eben jenem Clubgebäude, das hier auch in Berlin befindet. Das ist zum einen der Herr Erdgeist, hallo und guten Abend.
Wunderschönen guten Abend.
Die Bea.
Guten Abend.
Und der Andreas. Hallo. Und die sind heute hier zusammengekommen, um mal eine, aus Anlass, wie ich vermute, eine kleine Geschichte des Filesharings an den Mann zu bringen. Also es geht um etwas, was man auch liebevoll Privatkopie nennt manchmal.
Einfach datentauschen unter Freunden.
Datentauschen unter Freunden. Dezentrales Backup habe ich auch häufiger mal gehört.
Andere sagen dazu unerwünschte Vervielfältigung.
Man hört auch ab und zu den Begriff Raubkopie.
Das ist ja lächerlich.
Wieso ist das lächerlich?
Ich glaube, da kann unsere Innenjuristenkollegin Bea was zu erzählen.
Okay, das ist deshalb lächerlich, weil Raub bedeutet, dass ich Gewalt anwende gegen eine Person und das mache ich offensichtlich nicht, wenn ich etwas kopiere.
Woher kommt denn der Begriff?
Das ist ein Kampfbegriff der Urheberrechtsindustrie, die da einfach härtest mögliche Wortwahl zur brutalstmöglichen Aufklärung von fiesen Raubkopier-Mord-Terror anschlägt.
Also der Gegenkampfbegriff ist ja dann Content-Nafia.
Okay, also darum soll es heute gehen, um darum, wie digitale Güter, könnte man sagen, geistiges Eigentum kopiert wird, wie es verteilt wird, wie die Techniken dahinter ausgesehen haben und momentan aussehen. Und Anlass des Ganzen ist natürlich das Ende von Megaupload, könnte man sagen, das ist ja mittlerweile schon wieder eine Woche her, glaube ich, oder zwei, dass dieser große Share-Hoster, was das ist, klären wir im Laufe der Sendung auch noch, hochgenommen wurde, der Anführer des Share-Hosters, Kim Schmitz, wurde eingebuchtet zumindest mal. Und diese ganzen Sachen klären wir heute. Wir wollen aber wirklich sagen, euch mal nahebringen, dass das ja nicht irgendwie mit Megaupload angefangen hat und wahrscheinlich auch nicht zu Ende ist, sondern dass das schon sehr viel weiter zurückgeht. Also wie gesagt, eine kleine Historie des Filesharings. Und wenn ihr dazu was beitragen wollt oder könnt, und ich vermute, da gibt es den ein oder anderen von euch, der da schon eine Geschichte erlebt hat, könnt ihr gerne Folgendes tun. 0331 70 97 110 Und es ist natürlich klar, dass möglicherweise Leute sagen, ich will doch jetzt nicht damit ins Radio. Vielleicht ist es auch die Geschichte eines Cousins eurer Schwester.
Was war eure erste Privatkopie, die ihr euch von einem Freund besorgt hat? Wahrscheinlich ist es längst verjährt. Könnt ihr ja vielleicht eine lustige Geschichte erzählen.
Also welches ist das erste Privatkopie, die sich ein Freund von euch besorgt hat? Und euch danach erzählt hat?
Der Fachbegriff ist FOAF, Friend of a Friend, ein Freund eines Freundes.
So ein soziales Netzwerk sozusagen.
Ja, okay, der Freund eines Freundes. Wir fangen aber jetzt sozusagen ganz, ganz, ganz früh an in der Geschichte. Es gab nämlich tatsächlich eine Zeit, da gab es einfach mal noch gar kein Internet.
Was haben die Leute da abends gemacht? Wo haben sie ihren Porn her gehabt?
Wie haben die gegoogelt?
Keine Ahnung, aber angeblich, also in den Geschichtbüchern und Naturkundemuseen dieser Welt kann man sich das angucken, es gab vielleicht eine Zeit ohne Internet, aber selbst da wurde schon illegales Zeug getauscht. Also haben wir gerade gesagt, Raubkopie ist ein Kampfbegriff, genauso wie Content-Mafia. Verwenden wir diese Begriffe jetzt trotzdem?
Nein.
Sondern? Was sagen wir?
Wir reden von der Privatkopie.
Wir reden von der Privatkopie. Interessant ist ja auch noch kurz eingeworfen, dass Filesharing sozusagen eigentlich ja nur bedeutet der Austausch von Dateien.
Das Teilen von Dateien.
Das Teilen von Dateien, aber trotzdem, das illegal ist ja quasi schon mit inkludiert eigentlich, wann immer dieser Begriff fällt. Also wenn man sich in den Medien umguckt, dann muss man sagen, die Journalisten reißen sich schon immer zusammen, dass sie sagen, illegales Filesharing, aber es schwingt so mit.
Das U-Überrecht sagt aber nicht, dass es illegal ist. Das U-Überrecht spricht ganz normal von einer Privatkopie. Das heißt, wir haben ein Recht darauf, Privatkopien zu machen für unser Gebrauch, für den Gebrauch von Freunden, für den Gebrauch von der Familie. Und natürlich auch wissenschaftlich etc. Auf jeden Fall ist es absolut legal, eine Privatkopie herzustellen.
Also, sozusagen, solange ich eine Kopie an einen Bekannten, einem mir bekannten persönlichen, wie heißt das, natürlichen Personen weitergebe, ja?
Ja, da muss ein enges Verhältnis vorhanden sein. Das ist die eine Sache. Und dann gibt es auch noch Rechte auf Kopie für bestimmte Zwecke. Also, ganz am Anfang stehen natürlich diese wissenschaftlichen Zwecke, dafür darf ich Kopien herstellen. Auch Zitatrecht wird darunter und da gibt es Formregelungen, die man einhalten muss, aber es ist legal.
Okay. Trotzdem gibt es ja sozusagen viel juristische Verfolgung. Das werden dann sozusagen beide jeweils der einzelnen Tauschtechnik vielleicht noch mal genauer beleuchten können, inwieweit das eine Privatkopie ist oder nicht. Ich halte mal zur genauen Einordnung, das fällt mir gerade auf, wir haben vergessen, Bea ist sozusagen auch studierte Juristin und deswegen vom Fach und wird uns heute Abend da diese diuristischen Einordnungen geben. Zurück zu der Zeit, wo es kein Internet gab, da wurden ja die sogenannten Privatkopien auf Disketten weitergegeben, also diese kleinen Datenträger. Ich frage mich gerade, ob jetzt vor dem Radio Leute sitzen, die denken so, Disketten, was ist denn eigentlich eine Diskette? Und wenn man ihnen sagt, so dieses Symbol, was man zum Abspeichern bei deinem Wortverarbeitungsprogramm von deiner Wahl nimmt, das ist eine Diskette. Also kleine schwarze Scheiben, auf die man Daten speichern kann.
Ja, so was wie USB-Sticks nur mechanisch.
Und passt weniger drauf.
Ja, so irgendwie, wie viel waren das? 140 Kilobyte damals, zu C64-Zeiten pro Seite?
Ja, ich glaube, hat sich angefangen, aber waren schon 720 Kilobyte.
Ja, du bist ja auch so das...
Auf meinem ersten eigenen Computer ganz früher.
Das waren aber schon dreieinhalb Zoll Disketten.
Ja, auf den fünfundviertel Zoll Disketten passt dann auch weniger drauf.
Warte, warte, warte, man konnte da auch 720 draufschreiben, wenn man eins hatte mit 1, 2 Megabyte, aber andere Geschichten.
Ich wollte jetzt gerade sagen, wir könnten vielleicht wirklich mal die Probe als Exempel machen, falls da draußen jemand gibt, der nicht weiß, was eine Diskette ist.
Jetzt anrufen!
0331 70 97 110 Ich glaube, tatsächlich so weit sind wir noch gar nicht.
Ja, jetzt kommt die Onkel Andreas erzählt vom Krieg, oder?
Das ist schön, wie war das eigentlich damals, als du noch mit Disketten auf den Schulhof gegangen bist?
Damals im Osten, so alt bin ich schon, dass das Rechtssystem ein anderes war und das mit dem Kopieren noch nicht so parzell verboten, wie das heute der Fall ist, Daten getauscht habe. Da gab es aber in meiner Schule gar keinen, der auch einen Computer hatte. Das heißt, es gab diese Handvoll Leute in meinem Alter und wir trafen uns einmal die Woche in, damals gab es ja noch Jugendzentren, wo die Jugend was Anständiges gelernt hat, wie Assembler programmieren, Modelleisen bauen und Daten kopieren und das funktionierte so, dass man also seinen Rucksack dabei hatte mit Disketten und dann traf man sich einmal die Woche zum großen Kopieren und manche Leute brachten sogar ihren Computer mit, was relativ aufwendig war, weil damals gab es noch Röhrenmonitore, Laptops, da haben wir von geträumt und dann wurden die Daten tatsächlich von Diskette zu Diskette kopiert im persönlichen Austausch. Man ist dann auch mal Leute besuchen gegangen. Es gab zwar Modems, aber die strikte Warnung, sie nicht einzusetzen, weil die Stasi das nicht mag. Ja, und das waren die Anfänge.
Aber das ist eine kleine Randnotizie, die war mir neu zu sagen, es gab Modems, aber man sollte sie nicht einsetzen, weil sonst direkt die Leute an der Tür geklopft haben, oder?
Das war zumindest die Warnung, die mich ereilte, als mir dieses Gerät in die Hand gedrückt wurde. So, Kind, das ist ein Modem, da ist ein Bandspiel damit rum, aber schließ es nicht eine Telefonleitung an.
Es ist spannend, dass es dann im Westen die Post gewesen ist, die vorbeigekommen ist.
So groß sind die Unterschiede nicht. Ich glaube, auch in Bielefeld gab es eine ähnliche Einrichtung alle vier Wochen, wo man sich im Bunker am Ulmenwald traf, um Daten zu kopieren. Also, dass strukturell funktioniert, ist da auf beiden Seiten gleich, nur dass natürlich im Osten das mit dem Kopieren wesentlich entspannter gesehen wurde, als auch der Staat hat kopiert. Damals gab es von Robotron ein Betriebssystem namens SCP, das war im Prinzip CPM, nur dass das dringend CPM durch SCP ersetzt wurde. Ähnliches passierte mit einer Datenbank namens DBAs2, die plötzlich Reda-Bars hieß.
Nein, nicht nur das. Sie haben die CPUs durch Aufschleifen im Rasterelektronen-Mikroskop angucken nachgebaut.
Das wurde also alles gar nicht so ernst genommen damals.
Wir hatten ja nichts. Und da haben wir uns gefreut über jedes Stückchen Software, was auf unseren Rechnern lief, und da war einfach, dass es irgendjemand gehört, der etwas dagegen haben könnte, dass eine Software von irgendjemand anders noch benutzt wird. Das war einfach so hanebüchen, einfach so weit weg von der Realität, dass es dann auch eine Weile brauchte, bis man sich erst mal daran gewöhnte, dass Software auch Geld kosten können müsste. Das war so was, was bestimmt viele Hacker in der Anfangszeit noch so komplett anderer Kulturkreis nicht verstanden haben, dass da jemand an diesem Programm, was er eigentlich nur macht, dass man seine gekaufte Hardware für irgendetwas benutzen kann, dass der dann auch noch Geld dafür haben möchte, machte keinen Sinn, passte einfach nicht.
Da geht es aber um Programme, die, ich glaube sozusagen, die tatsächlich größere begegnen oder die erste breitere Publikmachung des Phänomens Privatkopie kamen, denke ich, mit Computerspielen auf. Also das ist sozusagen auch für Leute, die nicht Hacker waren und nicht sozusagen Computer-Nerds, dass wieder zu einer relativ normalen Beschäftigung wurde und dabei aber schon klar, worum es geht, weil die kosteten ja tatsächlich Geld und wurde auch kopiert. Wie ging das dann einfach noch so? Gab es da schon irgendwie technische Probleme? Wie ist das abgelaufen?
Na also auch damals haben natürlich die Hersteller solcher Software irgendwann begriffen, dass es vielleicht schlecht ist, wenn die Leute das kopieren und der Kopierschutz wurde erfunden. Und natürlich auch prompt umgangen, weil so ein Computer muss ja irgendwann das Programm ausführen. Also das Kopiergeschützte Programm muss ja irgendwann laufen. Also irgendwann ist es entschlüsselt und ausführbar im Speicher. Und das heißt schon rein logisch, dass es immer einen Weg gibt, da drum herumzukommen. Und die Leute hießen in der Szene damals Cracker, die also den Kopiergeschütz gecrackt haben. Dann gab es noch die Trailer, die damit gehandelt haben im größeren Maßstab. Später dann auch in der, da kommen wir gleich zu, als die Modems dann populär wurden zum Datentausch. Aber in der Tat waren es in erster Linie Spiele, mit denen es losging. Also die Phänomene, die man heute hat, so Film und Musik, das kam alles erst wesentlich später, als die Datenraten größer wurden und die Kompressionsverfahren besser. Da muss man sich überlegen, so ein Spiel war damals 140 Kilobyte groß oder 60 oder sowas.
Aber wir sagen irgendwie Trader und Cracker, das hört sich ja schon nach mafiosen Strukturen an. Also wenn man das gar nicht kennt.
Ja, das war der Underground, also das war ja nicht nur, die Motivationen waren ja vielfältig.
Ich hab mir damals auch ein paar Spiele angeguckt, wo ich mich einfach drüber geärgert habe, dass die abgestürzt sind mitten beim Endgegner und war dann so frustriert, dass ich mich da einfach mal auseinandergesetzt habe, wie das Spiel funktioniert. Ich habe dann dabei auch am Kopierschutz vorbeigekommen, der war halt nicht besonders anstrengend. Dann habe ich gesehen, dass die sehr ineffizient programmiert haben, habe dann das erste Mal mitbekommen, was so ein Compiler für Code erzeugt und ich als Assembler-Programmierer fand das sehr anstrengend, wie viel Redundanz dabei ist, habe das alles weggemacht, habe die Software schneller gemacht und am Ende hatte ich was, was nicht auf drei Disketten, sondern auf eine Diskette daher kam, nicht so oft abstürzte und habe dann noch einen kleinen Trainer dazu gepackt und das war so meine Motivation, da war irgendwie weniger dabei.
Aber mal ganz ehrlich, bist du sozusagen so eine Art Wunderkind gewesen oder war das tatsächlich sozusagen, wie die ganze Szene funktioniert hat?
Das war einfach Interesse, so Interesse wie funktioniert es und irgendwann kommst du halt da vorbei. Wir haben alle nur mit Wasser gekocht und irgendwann lernst du alle Tricks, wenn du dir so die Software anguckst.
Jetzt ist ja aber als Cracker warst du schon Lead.
Hab ich nie so wahrgenommen, also das ist die Außenwahrnehmung immer noch eine.
Andere als die des kleinen Kellerkinds, was da an der Software frickelt. Gab es da so eine Art Schwarzmarkt oder war das wirklich so ein, ich komm zu dir und gib mir dein Kopie-Mittelspiel?
Ja, das gab es natürlich schon immer. Das Kind auf dem Schulhof, das gemeint hat, ey kannst du haben, krieg ich auch einen Zehner von dir für die Kopie. Also das ist ein ganz bestimmter Menschenschlag, würde ich jetzt mal sagen, wo dann vielleicht auch der Begriff Mafia eher zutrifft. Also Files ist so halt irgendwie tauschen. Ich geb dir, du gibst mir und wenn ich dir ganz viel gegeben habe, musst du auch mal mit irgendwas rüberkommen. Aber es gab also auf jedem Schulhof irgendwie das Kind, das den Kram vertickt hat.
Das findet man dann auch in der Geschichte überall, in jedem Medium wieder. Jeder, der damit Geld zu machen sieht, dass er etwas billiger anbieten kann, was dann halt nicht direkt vom Hersteller kommt, gibt es in jedem Medium. Und wenn Leute Geld sparen wollen, um sich aber nicht den Stress geben, selber zu cracken oder selber zu suchen, da ist immer ein Markt und das ist aber nicht so die romantische Vorstellung, die man so vom Filesharing hat, dass ich mit guten Freunden oder fürs Karma Daten austausche, sondern da gebe ich jemandem Geld und heutzutage ist es auch viel Geld.
Muss man aber auch sagen, klar, das gab es schon immer und das wird es auch immer geben. Also sagen, das ist immer so ein Gegenpol zu diesem Filesharing, ist immer nur das romantische Lager vorher Ding, die waren auch schon damals nicht beliebt, ist aber auch Teil des Phänomens. Jetzt gucke ich mir an und denke mir so, okay, Privatkopie, die Grenze ist ja fließend und man kann so sagen, sehr schnell sehen, das wird auch als Ausrede benutzt, um das weiter zu geben. In dem Moment, wo ich dafür Geld verlange, ist es wahrscheinlich vorbei.
Ja, ja, das ist auf jeden Fall vorbei, genau, im Vorfeld wurde mich gefragt, wie lange man denn noch für U-Bahrechtsverletzung, also die Frage der Verjährung, belangt werden kann. Also das regelt sich im Normalfall nach den normalen zivilrechtlichen Vorschriften, das heißt am Ende des Jahres, wo der Schaden entstanden ist, also wo ich hätte eigentlich dieses Produkt kaufen müssen, dann danach drei Jahre, aber wenn ich eine Kopie mache und diese verkaufe, ja, dann verjährt die ganze Geschichte zehn Jahre, nachdem dieser Schaden entstanden ist und unabhängig davon nochmal 30 Jahre, so maximal 30 Jahre, da sieht man auch, dass dieser Eingriff von der Rechtsordnung viel mehr oder viel intensiver sanktioniert wird.
Das ist, weil es gewerbsmäßig ist?
Ja, weil ich in die Rechte, also in die Verwertungsrechte des Herstellers eingreife und ihm das wegnehme. Teilweise dauert es ja länger als drei Jahre, um an diese Information zu kommen, dass derjenigen sowas tut und deshalb auch die Verlängerung von Verjährungen auf bis zu 30 Jahre. Das ist was Besonderes im Rechtssystem. Wir haben in den meisten Fällen eben diese drei Jahre, so und dann ist gut, dann sollen die Leute sich nicht mehr streiten. Aber bestimmten tiefen Eingriffen haben wir die maximale Verjährung bis 30 Jahre, außer eben wenn ich jemanden umbringe. Das ist die einzige Sache, die nicht verjährt. Aber sonst haben wir die 30 Jahre Verjährung.
Also mit anderen Worten, wenn ihr damals auf dem Schulhof Disketten getauscht habt, könnt ihr jetzt ruhig davon erzählen, wenn ihr sie verkauft habt, solltet ihr diesen Fakt verschweigen, wenn ihr hier anruft.
Naja, ihr wisst schon, Freunde von Freunden.
Freunde von Freunden.
Also das mit dem Geld hat man schon mal geklärt. Jetzt noch mal zurück zu dieser Privatkopie. Kann man diese Grenze genau ziehen?
Nein, wir Juristen können kaum Grenzen. Kaum Grenzen. Einfach gerade ziehen. Das ist immer eine Problematik, das abzugrenzen. Also wer möchte jetzt vor Gericht stehen und dann nachweisen, wie eng oder wie weniger eng die Beziehungen sind, ist natürlich schwierig.
Man wird sich doch von einem guten Freund noch 500 Kilo bei downloaden dürfen.
Also klar, schwierig. Aber worauf ich hier nochmal hinweisen möchte, dieses Recht auf Privatkopie, was wir vom Gesetzgeber bekommen haben, wurde ja extrem unterlaufen durch diesen ganzen Kopierschutz. Also damit habe ich persönlich ein riesengroß Problem. Ich kaufe mir jetzt nicht Spiele, aber Musik und Filme und Soaps. Und kann die mir aber nicht auf meinen Laptop laufladen, sondern muss jedes Mal, wenn ich mir die angucke, die über mein Diskettenlaufwerk starten. Und meine Hardware geht daran tatsächlich kaputt. Also das ist so. Die ist nicht dafür gemacht, dass ich da mehrmals am Tag da Disketten rein und raus mache. Also ich habe...
Warte mal, Disketten, CDs? Ich dachte schon, Fernsehserien auf Disketten. So gut ist die Kompression schon.
Du hast ja dann am Ende auch noch für deine Festplatte gerade dafür, dass du eigentlich deine Privatkopie anschleppigen darfst, hast du dann noch eine Abgabe auf deine Festplatte und auf den Brenner und auf alle externen Geräte da noch schon bezahlt. Und dann darfst du trotzdem dieses Recht auf deine Privatkopie nicht wahrnehmen, weil du technisch daran gehindert wirst.
Um das nochmal klar zu ziehen, es ist also so, ich darf zwar theoretisch von jedem geistigen Werk eine Privatkopie machen, darf es aber praktisch oder auch theoretisch nicht mehr, wenn die durch einen Kopierschutz geschützt ist, oder wie?
Richtig. Also, es steht sogar im Muiwe-Gesetz drin, dass wenn da Kopierschutz drauf ist und ich diesen umgehe, obwohl ich einen Anspruch darauf habe, diese Sache zu kopieren, dann mache ich mich auch strafbar.
Das ist dann Umgehung eines besonderen Schutz?
Die ist strafbar.
Stand da nicht was von wirksam und ist sie nicht eigentlich unwirksam, wenn ich sie umgehen kann?
Ich habe jetzt auch so etwas im Kopf, dass es irgendwie damals mit der DVD-Encryption so war. Also Film-DVDs sind ja tatsächlich mit so einer Art Schüssel versiegelt und das ist ja irgendwann gebrochen worden und war irgendwann so leicht zugänglich, dass irgendwann mal ein Gericht mal gesagt hat, das ist jetzt kein Schutz mehr, kein wirksamer Schutz. Das wäre vielleicht nochmal interessant.
Noch eine Ergänzung dazu. Die Rechtsprechung hat da versucht, das ein bisschen zu korrigieren mit dem Kopierschutz. Und sie haben gesagt, auf dem Produkt muss ausdrücklich draufstehen, dass Kopierschutz besteht. Wenn es nicht ausdrücklich drauf ist, ist es ein Mangel. Und ich kann eben dann meine Rechte aus dem bürgerlichen Gesetzbuch geltend machen. Also ich kriege es nicht ohne Kopierschutz, aber es muss so ausgezeichnet sein, dass ich das nicht kopieren darf. Ist nett, aber die meisten Anbieter machen ja Kopierschutz drauf. Also dass mir das ja nicht wirklich hilft, diese Rechtsprechung.
Na doch, dann mache ich erst mal meine Kopie, dann gebe ich es wieder zurück und kaufe mir eine neue CD.
Aber das ist ja dann trotzdem verboten. Es geht ja auch darum, das zu klären, was das ist und was nicht.
Aber das hat ja in der Geschichte nie funktioniert. Erinnerst du dich damals, als die Software auf die Disketten kamen und dazu noch ein kleines Handbuch, was dann auf ganz braunem Papier, so dunkelbraunes Papier mit schwarzer Schrift kam, oder mit silbernem Papier mit weißer Schrift, was man nicht kopieren kann, sodass man dann entweder ganz mühsam das ganze Buch abtippen musste, um es einem Freund mitzugeben. So diese ganzen Kopierschütze in der Vergangenheit haben ja immer nur so eine Weile gehalten. Also so richtig ein effizienter Kopierschutz, der länger als, keine Ahnung, einen Monat gemacht hat, habe ich jetzt eigentlich nicht im Kopf.
Ne, in der Tat, wirklich ein Kopierschutz. Wo die PS3 schon relativ weit vorne ist, was das angeht. Muss man an dieser Stelle als Spieler sagen. Da gab es bis jetzt nichts einfaches.
Ja, da gab es auch nichts einfaches, aber wir haben ganz schön aufs Maul gekriegt.
Aber da Spiele kopieren geht meines Wissens nicht. Also nicht so einfach wie auf allen anderen Sachen. Aber das ist vielleicht ein anderes Thema, zu dem wir später noch kommen können.
Siehst du gerade im Chat, da meinte noch jemand, natürlich das Allergeilste war, dass du noch extra Hardware dazu bekommst. Hast du einen Dongle, den du hinten an deine Serielle ranstecken musstest, bevor du das Spiel spielen durftest?
Ich kenne das sozusagen von teurer Audio- oder Videobearbeitungssoftware. Da gibt es das heute noch, da gibt man so einen kleinen USB-Stick. Das gab es aber damals tatsächlich auch schon für diese Spiele.
Aber kein USB. Damit habe ich mir als Teenager mein Geld verdient, mit Architektensoftware, mit Dongle.
Bitte was?
Ja, ist verjährt, oder?
Nein, wenn du Geld damit verdient hast, dann nicht.
Andreas, nochmal, so soll es auch die Anrufer machen. Ein Freund von dir hat damals eine Geschichte erzählt, von einem Typen, der was gemacht hat?
Der hat Architektensoftware, die Dongle geschützt war, kopiert.
Wie hat er das denn gemacht? Da braucht man doch einen Dongle für.
Naja, das Jump If Equal durch einen Knopf ersetzt.
Ach, da kam aus dem Dongle nichts relevant, das was die Software noch bräuchte?
Ja, das war in den 90ern, also in den frühen 90ern.
Also um das mal in leicht verständlichen Worten zu erklären, es gab zwar diesen Schutz, der angesteckt werden musste und abgefragt wurde, aber das war so trivial, das aufzumachen, dass es sozusagen eigentlich kein Aufwand war.
Genau, es gab dann irgendwo in dieser Software halt die Stelle, wo er geguckt hat, ist denn der Dongle da, ja oder nein? Und wenn der Dongle da ist, springe mal nach da. Oder wenn der Dongle nicht da ist, springe nach da. Und wenn man diese eine Instruktion geändert hat, dann war der Dongle halt irrelevant.
So schnell kann es gehen. Jetzt hätte man eigentlich sagen, bei der ganzen Frage, Disketten, also Datenträger im eigentlichen Sinne auch noch sagen, Taping is killing the music industry. Weil sozusagen der andere große Zweig der Raubkopie früher, das sagen Musik auf Musik, Kassetten kopiert wurde.
Home taping is killing music.
Genau, Home taping is killing music. Aber das können wir vielleicht auch auslassen und werden uns dann gleich mal mit der ersten Datenübertragung per Kabel beschäftigen. Das waren verrückte Zeiten. Da geht es dann um Mailboxen. Und damit machen wir nicht Anrufbeantworter, sondern andere Dinge mit Modems und so. Aber das erklären wir gleich. Jetzt machen wir erst mal das Fritz-Info mit Nachrichten, Wetter und Verkehr. Und danach geht es hier weiter im Chaosradio.
Die zwei Sprechstunden.
Heute Chaosradio im Blue Moon mit dem Chaos Computer Club. Das heißt, von dem CCC sind Gäste zu Gast. Zum Beispiel der Herr Erdgeist, die Frau Bea und der Herr Andreas. Und es geht heute um eine kleine Geschichte des Filesharings. Wir haben gerade in der ersten halben Stunde schon erklärt, wie das damals war, als es noch kein Internet gab, als noch auf echten Datenträgern Dateien getauscht wurden. Da haben wir erfahren, das war eine sehr persönliche Sache. Man hat seine Disketten genommen, es irgendwo hingegangen, hat gesagt, hier tausch mal. Das gab es auch so ein bisschen größer organisiert. Wir wollen jetzt eigentlich gleich zum ersten Modem übergehen. Haben aber noch eine Sache vergessen. Und das ist natürlich so alt wie die Geschichte der Privatkopie, wie wir sie heute Abend nennen wollen, auf Wunsch der hier anwesenden Gäste. Genauso alt ist natürlich die Geschichte von den Leuten, die das Straf verfolgen wollten. Also die Sache steht uns in wirtschaftlicher Schaden. Wir möchten gerne diesen ganzen Leuten das Handwerk legen, damit die in Zukunft nicht mehr Dateien tauschen. Und da gab es zu dieser Zeit einen Herren, das war ein Freiherr, der hieß Gravenreut, und der hatte sich was sehr Schickes ausgedacht.
Na, meistens gab es eher eine Dame. Das war mal lustig. Genau, die Tanja. Wenn man nämlich seine Adresse leicht sinnigerweise in einer der einstägigen Computerzeitschriften, sei es eine Gamer-Zeitschrift oder Computerflow-Markt, hinterlassen hatte, dann hatte man Post bekommen. War da eine Diskette drin mit Software drauf und der Aufforderung, Software zurückzuschicken? Oder wurde einfach in den Brief gefragt, ob man nicht Software tauschen möchte. Wenn man darauf eingegangen ist, hatte man dann ziemlich schnell eine Abmahnung.
Jetzt muss man dazusagen, das ist tatsächlich nichts Ungewöhnliches gewesen. Also diese Art der Kontaktaufnahme, also irgendwie in der Computerzeitung zu schreiben, hier, lass mal Demos tauschen oder was auch immer, lass mal Briefwirtschaft anfangen, das gab es schon.
Natürlich, also wie Andreas vorher schon sagte, dass die Anzahl der Nerds am Anfang noch ziemlich spärlich waren und hat sich in seiner Stadt zwar getroffen, also in Berlin war es jetzt nicht so schwer, aber wenn man aus einer kleineren Stadt irgendwo auch in Westdeutschland kam, dann hatte man da in seinem Freundeskreis vielleicht noch einen, mit dem man Software getauscht hat, aber ansonsten war man darauf angewiesen, dass die Bundespost einem die Datenträger durch die Republik schippt. Und solche Anbahnungen haben dann natürlich immer so in Computerzeitschriften stattgefunden, die man dann immer so stapelweise aus dem Zeitschriftenhandel mit nach Hause genommen hat. Und dann hat man natürlich durchgeforschtet, wer da noch ehrlich Interessen hat und mit dem getauscht.
Tanya war eigentlich ein Fotomodel, das von Herrn Gravenreuth gemietet wurde. Der Freiheit Gravenreuth hat mehr oder weniger das Abmahnunwesen in diesem Sektor erfunden und damit auch relativ viel Geld verdient. Der zieht sich auch durch die Jahrzehnte. Zu dem kommen wir auch später bei den Mailboxen nochmal.
Wie waren damals die Strafen?
Meistens ging es ums Geld. Es war ja eher zivilrechtlich oder eigentlich war es eher schon die Einschüchterungstaktik. Verdammt, da schreibt gerade ein Anwalt, der will ganz viel Geld haben. Was mache ich denn jetzt? Mir selber einen Anwalt kann ich nicht nehmen, das ist verdammt teuer. Dann hat man sich an den gewendet und wenn man da erst mal angerufen hat, dann war man dann ziemlich schnell dabei, auch irgendwas zu bezahlen, nur um seine Ruhe zu haben und nicht verklagt zu werden. Und meistens war die Unwissenheit. Meine Großteil der Nerds hatte sich damals auf andere Dinge spezialisiert und nicht gerade Rechtsthemen. Und damit war dann dieses noch sehr schwammige, undifferenzierte Thema mit potenziell vielen Anwaltskosten, war dann so eins, was man ziemlich schnell lieber vor der Tür haben wollte. Und so hat sich dann der Herr Freiherd von Grafenreuth seine goldene Nase verdient.
Das erinnert aber wirklich tatsächlich sehr frappierend an heute, weil es genau dasselbe ist. Kriegt halt irgendwann Post von jemandem. So, dann haben wir das Kapitel Disket tatsächlich abgeschlossen, kommen jetzt zu sogenannten Mailboxen. Was sind Mailboxen und wie funktionieren die und wie kann man damit Dateien tauschen?
Mailboxen sind aufgekommen, als Leute meinten, dass so ein Computer, der DFÜ-fähig ist, also Datenfernübertragungsfähig, wenn der zu Hause rumsteht die ganze Zeit, dann braucht man ja immer eine Gegenstelle, mit der man kommunizieren kann. Und es funktioniert halt nicht, wenn nicht irgendjemand sagt, hier, ich wäre eine Gegenstelle. Also haben Leute einfach angefangen, einzelne Computer abzustellen, mit einem Modem zu verbinden und einem automatischen Programm, was eingehende Verbindungen annimmt. Und man konnte sich mit seinem eigenen Computer dahin verbinden und dann da Dinge drauf tun. Und eins der häufigsten Dinge waren Nachrichten zu schreiben, an jemanden anders, die dann jemand, der sich später darauf einloggte, auf derselben Mailbox abrufen konnte. Und das andere war natürlich neben den Nachrichten, da auch gleich noch Software hochzuladen und runterzuladen.
Also vielleicht nochmal ganz langsam für die Leute, bei denen das Internet aus der Wand fällt heutzutage. Danke. So ein Modem ist eine Kiste, die schließt man ans Telefon an. Und durch so ein Telefon kann man ja Töne übertragen. Dann kann man sagen irgendwie, ist eine Null und ist eine Eins. Und wenn man so... kann man Nullen und Einsen übertragen.
Das hört man am Anfang noch hier im Chaosradio Trailer auch. Das ist nur ein bisschen schneller, als was du gerade gepfiffen hast. Aber der Computer kann das auseinanderhalten.
Es hat halt nicht so eine große Bandbreite.
Aber ich habe so ein 2400-Baut-Carrier gepfiffen bekommen. Das haben die Modems mir geglaubt. Na ja, gut, dann hat man so ein Ding an seinem Telefon angeschlossen. So, eigener Computer, Telefon, Nummer anrufen. Auf der anderen Seite wieder ein Computer mit so einem Modem, das am Telefon hing. Und am Anfang tatsächlich mit aus Fischer-Technik gebauten kleinen Robotern, die die Gabel vom Telefon hoch und runter gedrückt haben, weil da tatsächlich der Hörer des Telefons in einem sogenannten Akustikkoppler drin lag, also ein Lautsprecher und ein Mikrofon auf dem Hörer des Telefons. Später dann mit Direktanschluss an die Leitung, war natürlich alles höchst illegal in den 80ern, also sowohl im Osten als auch im Westen. Und so gegen Anfang der 90er wurde das alles ein bisschen entspannter. Dann war das mit dem Osten vorbei und im Westen haben sie beschlossen, naja, wir weichen das mal auf und wir erlauben den Nutzern des Telefonanschlusses eigene Endgeräte anzuschließen. Und dann gab es auch die ersten Modems. Die coolen Modems waren natürlich trotzdem noch illegal. Man brauchte eine Postzulassung. Die schnellen Modems hatten keine. Na ja, und da sind natürlich Leute relativ schnell drauf gekommen, dass man darüber nicht nur kurze Nachrichten übertragen kann und sich mit dem Sysop der Mailbox unterhalten per Chat. Also es war dann so zwei Leute Chat. Sondern auch Dateien übertragen. Und da war die VARITZ Mailbox geboren. Wo man also seine Dateien hochladen und runterladen konnte. Dann also von der Diskette mit seinem Spiel ein Abbild erstellt, hat das hochgeladen, hat dafür ein anderes runterladen können.
Ja, na, das ging dann irgendwann auch so weit, dass Leute dann nicht nur ein Telefon, ein Modem an ihren Computer angeschlossen haben, sondern mehrere. Und dann wurde es ganz doll spannend, weil plötzlich konnte man wirklich live nicht nur mit dem Operator der Mailbox sprechen, sondern mit noch jemand anderem oder vielleicht sogar mehreren anderen Leuten, die sich auf demselben Rechner eingeloggt haben. Und das war dann, na ja, schon so, ja, die Geburt des Chats eigentlich.
Aber war das jetzt sozusagen, das hört sich für mich so an, okay, ich rufe jemanden an, das heißt, das ist eine Freundesgruppe von Leuten, die meinetwegen auch irgendwie weiter auseinander wurde, oder war das dann schon so richtig groß, dass da irgendwie, keine Ahnung, hunderte von Leuten auf so einer Mailbox, also nicht gleichzeitig, aber sozusagen insgesamt?
Dann auch schon, vielleicht nicht hunderte, aber so hundert Leute war nicht ungewöhnlich. Und die Telefonnummern wurden dann auch auf so Partys, zu denen man sich getroffen hat, wo man vielleicht Demos getauscht hat oder auf LAN-Partys, wurden dann die Telefonnummern auch getauscht und dann konnte man dann einfach da später anrufen. War halt immer noch ein Kostenfaktor, weil es ja nicht kostenlos gewesen ist, telefonieren und ging damals schon noch ziemlich ins Geld.
Also genau, früher war das ja so, kennen die Skype-User heutzutage auch gar nicht mehr, dass so ein Telefongespräch Kosten erzeugt, die abhängig sind von der Entfernung. Also wenn man ein Ortsgespräch führt, ist es sehr preiswert. Und wenn man ein Fernengespräch führt, ist es teurer und ein internationales Gespräch unbezahlbar. Deswegen gab es natürlich seine, man hatte seine lokale Mailbox, die halt im Ortsnetz war, die man irgendwie damals für 23 Pfennig pro Telefongespräch, weil eine Einheit anrufen konnte. Und für die längeren Entfernungen gab es dann spezialisierte Leute, die schon erwähnten Trailer, die über längere Entfernungen telefoniert haben, entweder weil Papa die Rechnung gezahlt hat oder aber weil sie Tricks kannten, um kostenlos zu telefonieren. Und jetzt kommen wir wieder mit Töne ins Telefon reinpfeifen. Blueboxing war damals also schwer modern. Funktioniert so, man hat eine kostenlose Nummer angerufen und damals haben die Vermittlungsstellen untereinander auch Töne benutzt, auf der Telefonleitung miteinander zu reden. Die konnte man emulieren. Das heißt, man konnte eine kostenlose Nummer anrufen, dann ins Telefon reinpfeifen. Und dann hat die Vermittlungsstelle am anderen Ende von dem, dem man kostenlos angerufen hat, aufgelegt und man konnte weiterwählen. Aber die eigene Vermittlungsstelle hat das nicht mitbekommen. Das hat das weiter als kostenlosen Anruf abgerechnet. Das war Blueboxing. Da gab es also Leute, die konnten das, die haben sich darauf spezialisiert. Die haben dann immer bei Mailboxen in Amerika angerufen, wenn es irgendwie frische Spiele gab und haben die runtergeladen, haben sie in den lokalen Mailboxen hochgeladen.
So war das. Das Blueboxing war wahrscheinlich hochgradig illegal sowieso.
Warum? Es ist einfach nur eine Art typisches Nutzerverhalten, was dann so Dinge mit dem Telefonnetz tut. Ich meine, man tut ja nichts physikalisch. Das sind ja gefährliche Schallwellen oder was?
Ich würde das ja als Verklärung im Nachhinein empfinden. Es war bestimmt Leistungserschleichung.
Was sagt die Juristin?
Ich bin mir nicht sicher.
Immer eine sichere Antwort.
Na gut, das kommt darauf an. Vielleicht ist mal jemand, das ist schon ein bisschen typisch für Juristen. Ja, im Prinzip schon, aber es kommt darauf an. Aber vielleicht ist euch ja irgendwas über den Weg gelaufen. Damals konnte er mal erzählen, 0331 77 97 110. Aber das ist natürlich auch so, die Dateien, die da getauscht wurden, die Mailboxen, das ist dann keine Privatkopie mehr, oder? Wenn man dann mit Leuten irgendwie, die man gar nicht mehr kennt.
Kommt darauf an, wie nah man sie kennt. Wenn man sonst keine Freunde hat, dann kann das ja vielleicht auch schon die engste, intimste Beziehung sein mit seinem Mailbox.
Ich weiß nicht, ob I'm forever alone als Richterargument zählt.
Ja, hier mal so für die Praxis. Also wenn man sich überlegt, okay, dann erzähle ich dem Richter halt die und die Geschichte. Die sind nicht nur juristisch geschuld, sondern das gehört zu deren Ausbildung, dass sie einschätzen können oder sie müssen das einschätzen können, ob der Zeuge, derjenige, der da was vorträgt, ob es glaubwürdig ist. Nicht bei Kindern, nicht bei psychisch Kranken, da gibt es Gutachter. Aber wenn normale Erwachsene da vorm Richterpult stehen und eine Geschichte erzählen, dann ist das vom Richter natürlich überprüfbar, ob das jetzt schlüssig ist, ob das nachvollziehbar ist oder ob das halt eine Story ist, der nicht gefolgt ist. Und er muss dieser Geschichte natürlich nicht folgen, sondern er kann im Urteil reinschreiben, er hält die Person halt nicht für glaubwürdig.
Und wenn ich da hinkomme und sage, die ganzen Mailbox-User, die 100 Leute, das sind alles meine Brüder, dann würde er sagen, vielleicht auch nicht. Vielleicht auch nicht. Da gab es auch einen größeren Fall, und da spielt in interessanter Weise dann auch wieder jemand eine Rolle, die jetzt aktuell auch in Schlagzeilen war.
Ja, ja, also Geschichte wiederholt sich und so, ne? Das war da sowohl der eine Name, den wir jetzt gerade genannt haben, Gravenreut, als auch Kim Schmitz, kim.com, Kim, Jim, Tim, Investor.
Also der von Megaupload?
Ja, der dicke.
Kim Solvent sozusagen.
Kim Solvent. Ja, muss man vielleicht noch ein bisschen weiter ausholen. Wie funktioniert das damals? Also man hat so eine Mailbox angerufen, man konnte ja nicht einfach runterladen, weil wenn man nur runter lädt, dann kommen ja keine Daten hoch. Das heißt, es gab eine sogenannte Ratio. Man konnte also für jedes Kilobyte, das man hochgeladen hat, dann drei oder vier Kilobyte runterladen. Das war so das Standardmodell. Auf Sharing-Basis, jeder bringt was, wie auf dem Schulhof, jeder muss mal ein bisschen was mitbringen. Und dann ist es auch in Ordnung. Und die Leute, die immer nur vorbeikommen und haben wollen, nicht mitbringen, sind die sogenannten Leacher. Die mag keiner und ansonsten teilen halt. Aber es gab in der Mailbox-Welt dann auch das Äquivalent zu dem Typen auf dem Schulhof, der den Kram für einen Zehner vertickt hat. Und das war in dem Fall in Deutschland tatsächlich als erster Kim Schmitz, der auf die Idee gekommen ist. Ja, bei ihm kann man Geld dafür bezahlen. Da muss man nichts hochladen, sondern man bezahlt Geld. Und noch eine andere Geschichte. Er hat auch im Fernsehen damals das Blue Boxing vorgeführt. Also alle haben lange Jahre Blue Boxing genutzt, um Daten hin und her zu schieben. Die Post hat es mehr oder weniger ignoriert, weil es sind keine tatsächlichen Kosten entstanden. Also kein tatsächlicher Schaden, sondern nur ein rechnerischer Schaden durch entgangene Telefonanrufe, die nie jemand gemacht hätte. Fanden sie also nicht so schlimm, aber nachdem es im Fernsehen lief, bei Monitor war das glaube ich damals, mussten sie natürlich was tun. Also Kim Schmitz zeigt im Fernsehen, wie Blue Boxing geht. Und danach musste die Post was tun, hat Filter installiert, und das ging nicht mehr so einfach, bis gar nicht mehr. Dann ist Kim Schmitz auf die glorios Idee gekommen, man könnte ja nicht nur das Runterladen von Dateien verkaufen, nein, man kann ja auch Calling-Cards verkaufen, also eine Art Kreditkarten, spezialisiert auf Telefonieren war das. Die hat er auch zum Verkauf angeboten. Also sozusagen jede Gelegenheit genutzt, aus dieser ganzen Datenkopierszene Profit zu schlagen, an allen Ecken und Enden, die rausgekommen sind. Und was dem Ganzen die Krone aufgesetzt hat und was also mehr oder weniger dazu geführt hat, dass Kim Schmitz in der Szene eigentlich seit 20 Jahren extrem unbeliebt war, war, dass er irgendwann also Ärger mit der Staatsanwaltpolizei, Urheberrechtsinhabern bekommen hat und dann auf die glorios Idee gekommen ist, die Daten seiner Kunden an Herrn Gravenreuth zu verkaufen. Also nicht nur, dass er erst den Leuten Geld dafür abgenommen hat, dass sie Sachen runterladen können. Nein, er hat hinterher dann auch noch Geld dafür genommen, dass er den Rechteinhabern erzählt hat, wer das war und natürlich straffrei rausgekommen ist.
Ein Hoch auf die Deals.
Nicht ganz straffrei, aber er wurde auf Bewährung verurteilt.
Nein, der Bewährung war erst später bei letsbite.com. Aus der Copyright-Nummer ist er damals komplett rausgekommen.
Den ersten Chor schon für Cracken hat er.
Genau, da kommt wieder Günther Freiherr von Gravenreuth ins Spiel. Besagter Anwalt, der das Abmahnunwesen erfunden hat und die Tanja Nolte Erndl in den Magazinen gespielt hat, um Leute anzulocken. Der war derjenige, der sozusagen mit Kimbell diesen Deal gemacht hat, den mit den Urheberrechtsinhabern eingefädelt hat und wahrscheinlich auch die Hand aufgehalten hat dabei.
Das ist ja sozusagen rechtlich noch eine ganz andere Sache. Gibt es diese Deals eigentlich sozusagen Vorschriften, wie man das macht oder ist das wirklich Verhandlungssache?
Man macht diese Deals immer häufiger. Das ist eine bekannte Tatsache. Man muss es nicht als Problem sehen in vielen Fällen, die wirklich langwierige Strafverfahren mit sich bringen. Macht das auch Sinn, die Deals durchzuführen? Also, das passiert so, dass Richter, Strafverteidiger und Staatsanwalt sich vor der Verhandlung, also Verhandlung wird eröffnet, und dann entscheidet man sich aber darüber, sich in einen anderen Raum zurückzuziehen, zu dritt, und zu überlegen, ob man nicht einen Kompromiss sozusagen aushandeln kann. Also, Grundlage dafür ist immer, dass der Angeklagte sich für schuldig erklärt. Also, sonst würde es ja gar nicht gehen. Und dann geht es nur noch darum, was für eine Strafe behängt wird. Also, ob Geldstrafe oder eben Freiheitsstrafe. Es gibt ja bestimmte Delikte, da muss ja mindestens Freistafe erfolgen. Es ist nicht unbedingt immer negativ, diese Deal zu machen. Aber man kommt auch immer mehr in Bereiche rein, wo wir Straftäter in unserem Rechtssystem eben nicht mehr verurteilen können. Weil sie legen dann so und so große Summe hin. Und gehen dann mehr oder weniger straffrei raus. Oder es gibt Deals, die sind aber schon im Vorfeld. Das ist dann mit den Ermittlungsbehörden, dass man da, das sieht man auch immer in den amerikanischen Filmen sehr oft, dass man Informationen gibt und dann dafür eben auch etwas von der Staatsanwaltschaft bekommt.
Aber das hört sich für mich schon an, wenn ich nur genug Kohle habe oder genug andere Leute verpfeife, kann ich eigentlich alles anschauen, was ich will?
Nicht ganz. Also es gibt Kapitaldelikte, da geht es nicht. Also wenn der Gesetzgeber sagt, wenn ich hier ein Mord begehe oder wenn ich einen Raub begehe, also einen echten Raub, dann Mindestfreiheitsstraf von einem Jahr oder gemeingefährliche Brandstiftung, Eingriff in den Straßwerkei etc. Solche Sachen müssen auf jeden Fall bestraft werden. Aber vor allem im Bereich von Vergehen kommt man teilweise mit Deals raus, wenn man das nötige Kleingeld hat. Was ist ein Vergehen? Es gibt Übertretungen, es gibt Vergehen und es gibt Verbrechungen. Übertretungen sind die ganzen Ordnungswürdigkeiten, also bei Rot über die Ampel laufen etc. Und Vergehen sind Straftaten, die mit Geldstrafe oder einer Freistrafe geahndet werden können. Und Verbrechen sind alles das, wo der Gästgewehr sagt, hier muss mindestens ein Jahr Freistrafe verhängt werden.
Ok, und zu sagen, dieses Mailboxing war dann wahrscheinlich ein Vergehen und kein Verbrechen.
Ja.
Ist das heute immer noch so, dass das Urheberrechtsdelikte, die auf Privatkopieaustausch zurückgehend vergehen sind?
Ja, es sind Vergehen.
Und ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass es da Bestrebungen gibt, zumindest von manchen Parteien, das als Verbrechen zu klassifizieren. Weiß ich, wisst ihr da was drüber?
Da wird ja mit geworben, die GVU sagt ja, dass Raubkopierer Verbrecher seien.
Ach, das ist in der Tat eine Lüge oder wie?
Ja, die Medien nutzen sehr oft juristische Begriffe falsch. Also es wird zum Beispiel ständig in den Medien von Mord gesprochen. Aber in den meisten Fällen ist es Totschlag, also als Beispiel. Und auch diese Unterscheidung zwischen Vergehen und Verbrechen wird nicht sauber gemacht. Und natürlich versucht man hier in dem Bereich, die Nutzer einzuschüchtern. Angst zu machen, das ist immer, wenn jemand eine Abmahnung im Briefkasten hat, wenn jemand was mit dem Anwalt zu tun hat, der etwas von einem will und auch noch Geld, Unterlassungserklärung, die auch noch strafewert ist, dann haben wir alle Angst. Weil wir haben das nicht in der Schule gelernt. Wir haben nicht Juristen in unserem Umfeld, in unserer Familie. Also das ist Einschüchterungstaktik.
Aber nun noch mal festzuhalten, dieser Spruch Raubkopierer sind Verbrecher ist also tatsächlich einfach falsch.
Erstmal Raubkopie an sich ist ja schon, also vielleicht können sie einfach durch die Logik sagen, wenn schon der Term Raubkopierer eigentlich nicht zu erfüllen ist, weil man ja nicht wirklich raubt, dann kann man auch einfach behaupten, es wären dann Verbrecher, weil das eine Null Aussage wird, wenn die Ex-Palsukrut liebet.
Ja, aber das ist doch viel zu kompliziert gedacht, verstehst du? Raubkopierer, wir können es auch umformulieren, es ist ja ein Werbespruch einfach, weil diese Raubkopierer sind Verbrecher und das liegt danach, also der Austausch, wie sagst du es so schön?
Der Austausch von, der nicht erwünschte Austausch von Daten.
Also sagen, in deiner korrekten Formulierung wäre es der Austausch von nicht erwünschten Daten.
Nicht erwünschte Vervielfältigung.
Nicht erwünschte Vervielfältigung von Daten ist ein Verbrechen, aber auch diese Aussage wäre falsch, weil es kein Verbrechen ist, sondern ein Vergehen.
Genau, aber die GVU ist ja sowieso auch, sind nicht die Guten.
Ja, aber ich glaube, das ist vielen Leuten einfach nicht klar, man hat ja irgendwann gelernt, okay, also wenn es mit den Höchstrafen, das ist nur, wenn es gewerblich ist und so, aber das ist halt kein Verbrechen, sondern ein Vergehen, das ist glaube ich vielen Leuten nicht klar, mir zum Beispiel bis jetzt eben.
Aber die ganze Nummer hat ja auch noch zivilrechtliche Komponente, oder? Also ich denke mal, dass auch dieser Deal dann eher auf dem zivilrechtlichen Teil stattgefunden hat, weil die haben ihm ja Geld gegeben, so der Kim Schmitz hat Geld dafür bekommen, dass er die Adressen rausgerückt hat und das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen, dass es Bestandteil eines Deals vor Gerichts war, sondern es war Bestandteil einer zivilrechtlichen Einigung.
Heutzutage ist es ja auch erst mal eine zivilrechtliche Abmahnung, die dann mit hohen Anwaltskosten, die eigentlich einen Großteil des Ärgers ausmachen, die man sich da einhandelt und wirklich vor Gericht gebracht wird, so nur in den aller wenigsten Fällen. Und wahrscheinlich haben auch die Abmahnanwälte da nicht wirklich Lust, dass es vor Gericht dann mal final entschieden wird. Wenn sich da wirklich mal jemand durchklagt, dann werden die da auch wahrscheinlich bis zur endgültigen Entscheidung das nicht abwarten und vorher einen Vergleich suchen, dass es keine Präzedenz gibt. Ist da so mein Bauchgefühl.
Was sagt die Juristin?
Ja, meine Juristin hat was auf dem Herzen und sagt, wenn man zu Unrecht abgemahnt wird, dann soll man sich tatsächlich wirklich dagegen wehren. Es gibt auch Fehler in den Protokollierungen, also nicht nur von den Verwertungsgesellschaften, also von den Abmahnanwälten.
Warte mal, ich möchte kurz unterrechnen, da geht es ja schon um diese Abmahnung, die aufgrund von Filesharing in Bittorrent und weiß-der-geier war.
Das machen wir mit der Chronologie nachher.
Genau, das machen wir nachher. Wir sind jetzt gerade so schön beim Kriminalisieren von Leuten, die wir unerwünschte Vervielfältigungen... Ich sage das einfach Raubkopien. Soll ich aber nicht. Andreas hat angerufen und wollte dazu auch was sagen. Andreas, hallo.
Erstmal wollte ich Erstgeist grüßen, wenn es geht.
Das geht nicht, aber gut.
Zum Thema Filesharing, Raubkopien etc. Man kann doch der Freund eines Freundes Geschichten erzählen etc. Ich erzähle mal eine Geschichte. Und zwar wurde die Geschichte in Assembler programmiert, nach DOS kompiliert, falls man das so versteht. Ihr versteht ja, was ich meine.
Könnt ihr die Geschichte trotzdem so halten, dass sie auch die Leute verstehen, die vom Radio sitzen?
Es wurde ein Programm geschrieben, was heute besser bekannt ist unter dem, was man unter Krankenkassen schreiben versteht oder vom Jobcenter oder vom Anwalt. Dieses Programm wurde damals in der Assemblersprache programmiert, nach DOS kompiliert, also rübergetragen, und wurde dann millionenfach unerlaubt sinnlos kopiert und Raubkopiert etc. im Auftrag der Bundesregierung, weil die hat das nämlich veranlasst. Es liegt jetzt in eurem Amessen, diese Geschichte zu glauben oder nicht zu glauben. Ich weiß nur, dass es so war, und ich kenne die beide. Sie war eine Hexen und er war ein Cracker. Und vielleicht glaubt man mir die Geschichte vielleicht doch nicht.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, wovon du redest, und ich glaube, das weiß auch kein anderer gerade.
Ich weiß es nicht. Die ganzen Schreiben, die du kennst, wenn du von der Krankenkasse ein Schreiben bekommst oder von deinem Anwalt oder von...
Was du sagen möchtest ist, wenn ich dich hinterbreche, dass ja auch die Regierungsstellen und die Verwaltung manchmal es mit dem Urheberrecht nicht so genau nimmt und unerwünscht vervielfältigte Versionen von Software einsetzt?
Ganz genau, und es geht noch viel weiter. Die Bundesregierung legitimiert dadurch ihr Verhalten und kriminalisiert aber andere, die private Daten austauschen. Wie heißt es doch immer so schön? Private Daten schützen und öffentliche Daten nutzen. Oder stand das nicht so in einer der Direktiven des CCC?
Wenn du von dem Fall weißt, wir haben da so einen Briefkasten, in dem da sogar noch mal braune Umschläge reinkommen.
Genau, da schickt man einen weißen Umschlag hin, auf dem drauf steht brauner Umschlag.
Dann schick uns doch die Geschichte mal, dann können wir gucken, ob wir das publik machen können, wenn das genug runterfüttert ist. Und da wären wir dann sehr interessiert daran.
Also ich kann nur eins sagen, ich bin wirklich der Letzte, der den Chaos Computer Club irgendwie auf der Schippe nehmen will. Oder es gibt genügend Leute, die sich wichtig tun wollten. Ich habe so ziemlich alle Datenschleudern hier gelesen. Und ich will mich hier auch wirklich nicht wichtig tun. Ich sage nur, es ist so. Und ich sage...
Ja, aber Andreas, wie gesagt, also die Geschichte zu sagen ist, hier kann hier nicht verherrschendlich dargestellt werden. Und deswegen würde ich einfach bitten, schreib es an den Club, unterleg es mit allen Dingen, die du weißt, oder lass es den Freund deines Freundes machen. Und dann entwickelt sich daraus vielleicht noch eine Geschichte. Wie ist es denn jetzt? Gibt es, hat man es jetzt schon mal gehört, dass irgendwie so von öffentlicher Stelle im großen Stil raufkopiert wurde?
Also im großen Stil sind mir keine Geschichten bekannt. Es ist allerdings einem Freund, eines Freundes mal passiert, dass bei einer Hausdurchsuchung, die haben da so Live-CDs, mit denen sie die Rechner untersucht haben. Und da fanden sich also irgendwie verschiedene Versionen, eine Forensiksoftware drauf.
Also Live-CDs heißt sozusagen, ich kann die CD in den Rechner schieben, den Rechner davon hochfahren, ohne dass das Betriebssystem von der Festplatte lädt.
Genau.
Und kann damit den Rechner untersuchen.
Genau. Und auf dieser CD, die haben die Beamten im Laufwerk vergessen, als sie da gegangen sind. Und da fanden sich also drei verschiedene Versionen einer Forensik-Software plus einen Key-Generator drauf auf der CD.
Also viele Key-Generator sagen für Leute, die es nicht wissen, manche Software verlangt die Eingabe eines Codes, also viele verschiedene Zeichen, die schwierig zu merken sind. Und wenn die sich diese Zeichenketten generieren lassen und nicht vom Hersteller abgefragt werden, dann ist das ein sogenannter Key-Generator. Das heißt also ein sehr deutliches Hinweis darauf, dass die auf dieser CD verwendete Software möglicherweise nicht recht ist.
Man hört ja immer wieder davon, wie schlecht die LKAS ausgestattet sind.
Das scheint der Wahrheit zu entsprechen. Ich hatte da eine Geschichte vom Freund eines Freundes auch, der hat geschäftlich mit der Verwaltung zu tun und hat denen eine Software verkauft, die so Vorgänge verbucht und eine Datenbank speichert. Und irgendwann wurde er von einer anderen Behörde eines anderen Bundeslandes angefragt, ob er denn nicht denen mal eine Anbindung an so ein Tool hacken möchte, was irgendwo woanders läuft. Also ein bisschen Konsolidierung von so Daten. Dann hat er mal geschaut, was die Gegenseite für so ein Protokoll spricht, um das dort auch zu implementieren. Und dann ist ihm aufgefallen, das Protokoll kennt er. Und dann fiel ihm auf, dass nicht nur die eine Behörde, der das verkauft hatte, sondern inzwischen alle Behörden bundesweit diese Software unlizenziert benutzt haben. Das ist halt vom Freund eines Freundes gehört.
Der hat nicht erzählt, ob er damit dann Millionen geschäffelt hat, weil er sagen die ganzen Einzelplazizenzen dann nochmal.
Ich kann jetzt nicht sagen, welche Behörde das war, aber die verklagt man nicht.
Sehr schön. So, da haben wir jetzt also Disketten und Mailboxen.
Ich habe ja irgendwie noch meine Lieblingsgeschichte, die hier unbedingt noch loswerden möchte. Weil ganz früher konnte man nämlich dieses Modempfeifen nicht nur am Anfang vom Chaosradio hören, sondern einfach auch wenn man das Tagesprogramm, also das Abendprogramm ganz normal eingeschaltet hat, da gab es plötzlich Software über die Luft, per UKW. Zu den Zeiten, als die Programme noch nicht so richtig groß waren, also so groß wie jetzt JavaScript-Schnipsel, da hatte man dann einfach seinen UKW-Empfänger auf den richtigen Kanal, hat seinen Kassettenrekorder daneben gestellt und dann das Programm aus der Luft empfangen.
Aber das war ja keine unerwünschte Vervielfältigung.
Das ist halt total unklar. Damals war, was da verteilt wurde, war halt die Software, die da gerade rum lag bei demjenigen, der da gerade DJ am Pult war. Später gab es dann die Experimente noch mit dem Fernseher, wo extra Geräte verkauft worden sind, wie man da so rechts unten per Sauglocke an seinen Fernseher ranbammeln konnte, wo da vier Helligkeitssensoren drin waren, die dann die fluktuierenden Pixel rechts unten im Fernseher dann einfach gescannt haben.
Das war WDR Computer Club, oder? Mit Klaus & Klaus.
Ja, genau.
Verrückt. Also nach dem mailboxen gab es noch Experimente mit Einwegtechnik. Und dann kam aber doch schon bald das Internet. Und darüber reden wir dann in der zweiten Stunde des Chaosradios heute hier auf Fritz. Die zwei Sprechstunden. Holy Bleep von Mizuki's Last Chance, eine Mischung aus Dubstep und Chiptunes, die ich sehr gelungen finde, die es auch umsonst im Netz gibt auf Bandcamp. Und die ist eigentlich im Chaosradio gelandet, wo es heute um die Geschichte des Filesharing geht. Anlass ist, dass einer der größten aktuellen Anbieter von Filesharing, nämlich der Sharehofter Megaupload, zugemacht wurde. Da spielt auch eine Person eine Rolle, die in der Sendung jetzt schon aufgetaucht ist, nämlich ein sogenannter Kim Schmitz. Und wir erzählen heute mal, wie so im Laufe der Zeit die digitalen Güter untereinander ausgetauscht wurden. Wir haben jetzt sozusagen schon die, ich will mal sagen, Steinzeit des Dateientauschs hinter uns gebracht und kommen jetzt zu den Anfängen der modernen Neuzeit, nämlich dem Internet. Zu Gast sind heute Frau im Chaos Computer Club Erdgeist, Bea, und Andreas.
Tachchen.
So, und jetzt machen wir Internet.
Da ist man dann endlich wieder zu Hause.
Genau, jetzt ist es ja so, dass das Internet, so wie wir es heute kennen, ist ja nicht immer so dick und schnell gewesen. Das war ja am Anfang ein bisschen langsamer. Jetzt ist so, meine Erinnerung ist es so, der erste große Filesharing-Dienst, der, ich sag jetzt mal, IP-basiert im Netz, also die sagen, über diese Netzwerk- irgendwie Sachen funktioniert, waren LAN-Partys. Also das heißt, noch mal irgendwo hingehen und dann Dateien tauschen, weil das Internet selber noch zu langsam war.
Da hatte man dann irgendwann nicht mehr seine Disketten mitgenommen auf die Partys, um sie dort zu tauschen, sondern da nahm man gleich den gesamten Computer mit, stellte ihn dann dahin und hatte in der Zwischenzeit, wie man sich da über das LAN die Daten seiner Freunde kopiert hat, dann auch gleich noch Spiele gespielt. Und daher kommt auch die öffentliche Wahrnehmung, dass man diesen LAN-Partys größtens jetzt geballert würde. Ich glaube, so einer der Hauptgründe war, einfach einen LAN aufzumachen und dort zu gucken, was an spannenden Programmen spielen, Musik bei den Freunden rum. Obwohl, Musik war so früh doch gar nicht dabei, weil da gab es die Mods, diese kleinen Musikstücke, die da liebevoll von Programmierern noch zusammengestückelt wurden, die dann auch eine handliche Größe hatten, dass sie noch mit Disketten draufpassten. So wie heute so MP3s, die Qualität war das noch nicht. Oder so Chiptunes, die wir gerade gehört haben, war bei den C64 Hackern immer ganz beliebt und die wurden dann natürlich auch getauscht. Also Musik tauschen damals auch, vor MP3 war es einfach unrealistisch, so viel Daten mitzunehmen.
Wobei das damals natürlich zum größten Teil selbstgemachte Musik war. Das ist dann die ganze Ecke, Demo-Szene und so weiter und so fort. Also viel von dem, was damals getauscht wurde, war dann auch selbstgemachte und handgestrickte Musik. Also die normale Musik aus dem Radio, die konnte man nicht nehmen und auf eine Diskette tun, sondern das war spezielle für den Computer programmierte Musik.
Okay, aber ansonsten diese LAN-Partys war jetzt auch irgendwie so keine technische Herausforderung, oder? Also die spannende Frage war da, wie du sagen willst, da ging es ja nochmal um den Kopierschutz, dass der irgendwie weggekriegt werden musste?
Na, das war meistens schon fertig, das brachte man auf seiner Festplatte mit und dass auf den LAN-Partys da selber noch irgendwas Proaktives passiert, das kam auf die Szene an. Es gab natürlich in der Demoprogrammiererszene und in der Cracker-Szene gab es natürlich dann auch, dass man noch schnell auf Partys, wo man dann am Ende eine Demo vorgeführt hat, den Code fertig gemacht hat oder noch schnell den Trainer für den Crack, den man gemacht hat, noch schnell fertig programmiert und dann dazu zeigen, aber ansonsten auf den LAN-Partys selber eher so Konsum.
Das erste Mal, wo man sich über Technik nicht mehr so richtig viel Gedanken machen musste und dann hat damals auch schon eine Rolle gespielt, also als es das langsame Internet gab, noch über Modems, eine Sache, die heute immer als Werbung manchmal auftaucht im Netz, ist Usenet. Das ist ja, muss ich ehrlich gestehen, ein Teil dieser ganzen Netzgeschichte, die sowohl damals als auch heute komplett ausgelassen habe. Was ist das Usenet eigentlich und wie tauscht man dort Dateien?
Das Usenet ist also aus den Zeiten, wo es noch kein WWW gab im Internet, für viele Leute ist es ja dasselbe, aber es ist tatsächlich so, dass dieses Webklicken im Protokoll irgendwann dazugekommen ist. Das Usenet ist älter. Das kann man sich vorstellen als eine Art verteiltes Forum. Das heißt, es gibt nicht irgendwie einen Rechner, auf dem ein Forum zu einem Thema ist, sondern es gibt viele Rechner, die viele Foren zu allen Themen haben und untereinander austauschen. Technisch funktioniert das als so ein nettes Flatfill-Verfahren. Das heißt, man hat Server, die reden miteinander. Dann schreibt man seine Textnachricht, so was wie, hallo, ich bin heute Morgen aufgestanden, das Wetter war schön, wie geht es euch so? Ja, ein bisschen ausführlicher. Man hat schon mehr als 140 Zeichen gehabt, also es war ein bisschen moderner, dieses Protokoll, als Twitter. Und dann hat man das an seinen News Server geschickt, eine sogenannte News Group. News Groups gab es die großen sieben Hierarchien, also die waren geordnet nach zum Beispiel SCI für Science, für wissenschaftliche, Recreational, was gab es noch, COM für Computer und SOC für Society. Und da gab es ALT, Altstand für Alternative und für alles andere. Und so die ersten Pornos, die ich runtergeladen habe, waren also in Textformen und kamen aus ALT.erotica hieß es glaube ich, genau, ALT.erotica, News Groups, erotische Texte. Und irgendwann haben sie auch angefangen, darüber Dateien auszutauschen. Aber Flatfill, genau. So ich schreibe meine Nachricht, ich schicke das an meinen lokalen Server in eine bestimmte News Group. Und mein News Server, mein Usernet News Server ist verbunden mit anderen Servern. Und redet mit denen, sagt denen, pass mal auf, ich habe eine neue Nachricht mit folgender Nachrichten ID. Dann sagen die auf der anderen Seite, ne, habe ich noch nicht. Und dann schickt er dem das rüber. Das schicke ich also, schickt den News Server in alle Richtungen an alle angeschlossenen Server. Irgendwann passiert das natürlich, dass die Nachricht überall ist. Das heißt, der nächste News Server sagt seinem Nachbarn, du, ich habe hier eine Nachricht, eine andere sagt, kenne ich schon. Und dann ist die überall, so nennt es Flat Filling. Funktioniert wunderbar, funktioniert auch, wenn man News Server wegfällt, weil dann läuft es einen anderen Weg, ist also sehr, sehr resistent. Kommt auch aus Zeiten von Vor-IP, also das funktioniert auch schon über Modems mit USCP, aber dann über IP so richtig. Und da sind Leute darauf gekommen, dass man damit ja auch Dateien austauschen kann, und zwar indem man die Dateien als Textnachrichten codiert. Man nimmt also sein Binary, zerlegt das in ganz viele Stücke und dann heutzutage würde man Base64 nehmen, gab es damals noch nicht, wurde UU-Encoded und dann hat man also sein Spiel genommen, da 100 Textnachrichten draus gemacht, dann gab es Alt-Binaries-Vers-PC-Games und dann hat man da sein Spiel hochgeladen.
Aber ich kann mir jetzt wirklich vorstellen, also man kann das ja heute spaßeshalber machen, man nimmt einen Rechner eine ausführbare Datei, öffnet die mit einem Textelitor, dann stehen da verschwurbelte Zeichen.
Genau.
Und das hat man dann quasi so was, im Prinzip hat man dann in dieses Usenet reingepostet als Textnachricht, 100-fach, 100 kleine Stücken.
Man kann sich vorstellen, dass diese Textnachrichten dann einfach die binäre Repräsentation sind. Also so ein Byte ist ja eine Zahl von 0 bis 255, bestehend aus zwei hexadezimalen Zahlen. Und die einfachste Möglichkeit, das zu entkoden, wäre einfach da 0 bis 9 und A bis F rauszumachen und dann aus einem Byte mal 2 zu machen. So kann man sich das vorstellen, dass da dann was, naja, ist nicht menschenlesbar, aber es geht zumindest dann, weil es nicht mehr binär ist, geht es als Textnachricht durch.
Und musste man das von Hand machen, oder gab es dann dafür auch?
Ja, da gibt es natürlich Software. EMAX konnte das. EMAX war aber nicht die einzige Software. Ich kenne tatsächlich Leute, die haben das von Hand gemacht. Die haben dann alle 100 Nachrichten von Hand runtergeladen, von Hand zusammengesetzt und weggeschrieben. Und ich war total liet, weil ich konnte in EMAX mit Regular Expressions sagen, setze mir das zusammen und pack es mir am Stück aus.
Aber das ist gar nicht so antiquiert. Ich meine, wenn du mal in eine Mail rein guckst, was meinst denn du, was da in deiner Mail reinkommt? Sind das Binär-Daten?
Der Mail ist antiquiert.
Nee, in der Mail hängen hinten auch noch UDABase64 encoded.
Wir verlassen dem Pfad des allgemeinen verständlichen Radioprogramms.
Ich wollte nur sagen, die Art und Weise, wie da Text draus gemacht wurde aus binären Programmen, ist heute immer noch dieselbe, wenn du eine E-Mail empfängst. Deswegen ist die immer noch ein bisschen größer als die eigentlich zu verschickende Datei.
Also, Usenet war lange sehr, sehr wichtig. Wie gesagt, vor Erfindung des Webs war es eigentlich einer von drei oder vier Services, die man so hat im Internet. Das erste Protokoll, das erfunden wurde, war Dateitransfer natürlich. FDP stammt aus den frühen 70ern. Hat tatsächlich auch als Verbreitungsmedium für Wärs lange Zeit eine Rolle gespielt. Also Leute haben sich FDP-Server gesucht. Möglichst welche, wo man was hochladen konnte und dann haben die einfach hochgeladen, dann ist die URL rumgegangen und gut war. Nee, der Pfadname URLs gab es ja auch nicht. Dann gab es Chat. Also, IRC ist auch ein relativ altes Protokoll, ist Ende der 80er entstanden. Mails, SMTP und Usenet. Das waren so die vier wichtigen Kommunikationsmedien, die man im Internet hatte, bevor das Web angefangen hat. Und also alles, was heutzutage in Foren abgehandelt wird, ist darüber passiert und deswegen hatte das auch jeder. Also jede Universität hatte ihren News Server. Und CompuServe war ja damals irgendwie, also bevor das Internet populär wurde, gab es ja verschiedene Versuche, proprietäre gegen Internetse aufzubauen. AOL erinnert sich vielleicht der eine oder andere, CompuServe war so eins. Und die haben sich irgendwann ergeben und haben gesagt, okay, ja gut, wir machen auch Internet. Man hatte bei seinem Provider halt immer seinen News Server zu stehen, zu dem man sich verbunden hat. Und da kamen natürlich auch immer alle Bineries drüber. Und da gab es damals einen relativ wichtigen rechtlichen Streit drüber, CompuServe. Da gab es also eine Klage gegen den Geschäftsführer von CompuServe Deutschland wegen illegalen Raubmordkopien auf News Servern. CompuServe hat damals gewonnen, übrigens. Was der Grund ist, dass es das Usenet tatsächlich immer noch gibt.
Also das war zum ersten Mal die Frage, ob der Übermittler der Nachrichten auch dafür verantwortlich gemacht werden kann, dass da Raubkopien durchgehen.
Genau, genau. Das, was man heutzutage als Providerprivileg kennt, wurde damals also ausgestritten. Ob derjenige, der diesen News Server betreibt, dafür verantwortlich ist, was seine Nutzer da hochladen und darüber kommt.
Jetzt ist es ja so, dass Usenet, wie ihr es gerade beschrieben habt, sozusagen eine Ansammlung von Text, den man auch irgendwie missbrauchen kann, um Dateien auszutauchen.
Das ist ja nicht Missbrauch, das ist ja der Gebrauch.
Ja, und jetzt gibt es aber dieses letzte Mal Usenet heute noch. Also es blinkt in Bananen auf irgendwie. Wenn Freunde im Internet danach was suchen, dann tauchen sie auch hier, laden sie das Usenet runter, bezahlen aber Geld. Ist das noch dasselbe Usenet oder ist das nur der Name?
Das ist noch dasselbe Usenet, aber im Laufe der Zeit war einfach dieses Flat Fill, was Andreas beschrieben hat. Ist natürlich, wenn du anfängst, riesige Datenmengen, ganze DVDs da hochzuladen, da wird das echt viel Traffic. Und da hatten viele Leute keinen Bock mehr drauf. Und dann haben sie gesagt, naja, für diese ganzen Diskussionen, Sports, machen wir es einfach weiter. Die kann man weiter einfach so kostenlos abonnieren. Aber die ganzen Binärkanäle da, so Alt-Binary, die synchronisieren wir einfach nicht. Wenn da jemand etwas bei uns absetzen möchte, dann fragen wir gar nicht nach dieser Nachricht. Haben wir aber diesen einen schönen, kostenpflichtigen Dienst, bei dem geht das. Da kannst du dann, damit wir diese Informationen von den Gegenstellen reinbekommen, müssen wir den Traffic bezahlen, kostet uns Geld, und deswegen verkaufen wir es dann weiter als kostenpflichtigen Service. Und so wurde es dann zum Zweiklassen-Usenet, wo man dann den schmalen Textversionskram natürlich immer noch bekommen hat. Einfach so, aber wenn man Binärdaten runterladen wollte, hat man dann dafür bezahlt. Und dieses Modell hat sich dann im Laufe der Zeit weiterentwickelt, sodass es heute Leute gibt, die einfach auf demselben Protokoll, aber auf richtig großen, dicken, angebundenen Servern, die die Möglichkeit per UUCP, also diesem Protokoll, was im Usenet gesprochen wird, auch Binärdaten runterzuladen. Und du bezahlst da eigentlich dafür, dass sie dir so bulletproof das anbieten. Na, du kannst eigentlich nicht belangt werden. Du machst eine sichere Verbindung zu diesem Verserver auf, zu diesem UU-Netserver auf. Und wo der die Daten herbekommt, ist dir egal. Und du hoffst einfach darauf, dass er schon nicht die Downloads mit dir assoziiert. Und dann am Ende dem Strafverfolger.
Du hoffst darauf, dass er nicht die Kim Schmitz macht? Okay, das also zum Usenet. Und dann ging es ja richtig los mit dem, ich nenne es jetzt im Mangel eines anderen Begriffs, mit dem richtigen Internet. Napster, anyone? Also war Napster nicht sozusagen... 4 zu 4 sagste, ja. Also war das nicht der Beginn des großen übers Netz Filesharing auch für den Normalverbrauch? Also nicht Leute, die sich irgendwie auskannten, sondern mehr oder weniger für jedermann.
Ja, also in den Anfangszeiten, da war auch Napster und Nutella waren noch Programme für die Nerds, bevor sie dann ein schönes Use-Enterface bekommen haben. Aber die Nerds haben dann schon... Da war dann auch die Zeit, wo dann MP3s das erste Mal aufkamen, wo dann auch wirklich... Dann was auch Leute da draußen interessierte. Also so mit Software, auch noch gekrackte Software, wo man sich nicht sicher war, war dann halt nicht für jeden. Aber als es dann plötzlich auch Musikdateien gab, da waren dann plötzlich diese Dienste, die einem per Peer-to-Peer, also was heißt, von einem sehr entschärmten Bekannten, sich Musik herunterzuladen, war dann plötzlich voll am Wog. Man konnte dann die CD, die man sich eigentlich hätte kaufen müssen, für umme... Na ja, herunterladen. Sie materialisierte sich, wenn man sie irgendwo gefunden hatte, in diesem Netz, plötzlich auf der eigenen Festplatte. Und man konnte sie dann mit so Vim-Emp oder was man auf seiner Plattform hatte, dann auch anhören und musste die CD nicht mehr kaufen. Da hatte man auch einen handfesten Geldwerten Vorteil. Und dasselbe gilt natürlich auch für Spiele. Sodass es dann das erste Mal im Mainstream angekommen ist damit und nicht nur die Nerds interessiert hat. Aber das waren damals echt noch hakelig Protokolle, wo man einen Ordner hinlegen musste. Und dann hat dieses Programm da durchgescannt. Und dann musstest du nach Dateinamen suchen. Und dann hat er dann mit allen anderen, mit denen du da verbunden warst, mal gefragt, sag mal, habt ihr die Datei? Und die haben dann weiter gefragt. Und dann ging das so explosionsartig, zehn Schritte weiter. Und wenn irgendjemand durch Zufall bei einem seiner verbundenen anderen Notes diese Datei gefunden hat, dann hat er gesagt, ja, gibts da. Und dann konnte man sich dahin verbinden und den Dateitransfer starten. Hört sich, naja, ziemlich ineffizient an. Und war es auch. Und deswegen hat es niemals etwas kaputtgehoben.
Aber kurz so, dass alle Rechner im Prinzip mehr oder weniger miteinander geredet haben und direkt ohne eine zentrale Instanz, oder?
Ja, also es gab natürlich immer zentrale Instanzen, um erstmal noch eine Liste der gerade aktiven IP-Adressen. Also man muss es ja irgendwie seeden. Also man muss dafür sorgen, dass man wenigstens mal ein paar hat, die schon in diesem Verbundnetz dabei sind. Und die wurden immer noch von einer zentralen Stelle ausgeliefert. Aber ansonsten war danach die Information, wer sonst noch in diesem Netzwerk beteiligt ist, wurde dann schon peer-to-peer auch mit ausgetauscht.
Also zwischen allen Nutzern quasi. Ist das dann rechtlich eine andere Sache gewesen? Oder ist das dann immer noch, sprechen wir immer noch hier vom ja, Privatkopien, oder ging es dann los, ist das eigentlich jeder Teilnehmer auch, dass dann diese Uploader, Downloader Unterteilung?
Das ist ja schon keine geschlossene Benutzergruppe mehr. Also damit kannst du schwerlich noch irgendwie argumentieren. Also bei so einer Mailbox, wo alle theoretischen Zugangsschlüssel haben müssen, um daran teilzuhaben, kann man ja argumentieren, das sind das meine Freunde, aber spätestens dann, wenn automatisch neue Peers hinzugefügt werden, die irgendwo im Netz gefunden werden, ist es einfach keine geschlossene Benutzergruppe. Du wirst echt eine harte Zeit haben, den Richt dazu erklären, dass das noch eine Privatkopie, die du nur Freunden zur Verfügung stellst, ist.
Jetzt habe ich irgendwie im Ohr, dass es sowas gibt, wie Download aus offensichtlich rechtswidriger Quelle ist illegal, aber wenn das nicht der Fall ist, dann nicht. Stimmt das oder ist das was Gutes da?
Ja, also wir kennen diese Formulierung ziemlich gut, also die offen kundige rechtswidrige Quelle. Gute Frage, was ist es? Das hat sich leider in den letzten Jahren so verschärft, dass es sämtliche Filesharings sind. Also wenn nicht der Rechteinhaber dieses Produkt zur Verfügung stellt, dann muss man davon ausgehen, dass es eben eine Zwischenquelle ist. Also jemand, der zwischengeschaltet ist. Und dann soll es schon offen kundig sein. Also ganz klar hier wird argumentiert, um ein bestimmtes Ergebnis zu erreichen, dass man sich mit diesen einzelnen Portalen da nicht auseinandersetzen muss, was ist jetzt noch glaubwürdig oder was nicht etc. Sondern entweder wir haben eben anerkannte Verwerter. Das ist dann offen kundig rechtmäßig. Und die anderen Bereiche, die fallen dann unter unsicher. So und da wird aber kaum zugestanden, dass man das nicht erkennen konnte, dass hier auch Daten zum Kopieren bereitgehalten werden, wo halt Lizenzrechte verletzt werden.
Es gibt zum Beispiel, was ich dann immer gerne ranziehe, es gibt eine Plattform, die heißt recordlabel.com, also ohne die Vokale. Und da werden Remixe von bekannten Songs, also von auch bekannten Künstlern zur Verfügung gestellt und auch manchmal von neuen Stars quasi. Und das gibt es schon sehr lange und das ist auch legal, weil die Künstler da mitmachen. Aber wenn jetzt so ein unbedarfter User dahin kommt, kann er das quasi eigentlich nicht unterscheiden. Weil das sind nicht die Künstler selber, die das halt anbieten, sondern das ist halt auf jeden Fall so eine Art Magazin, Musikmagazin, die da Downloads anbieten. Das heißt, er müsste nach der aktuellen Rechtsprecher eigentlich sagen, ok, ich lade da nichts runter, weil das ist für mich schon offensichtlich rechtswidrig.
Ja, das ist schwer, das abzugrenzen. Das ist eine Ausdehnung, die man natürlich bezweckt, um sämtliche Möglichkeiten zu minimieren, dass hier Kopien hergestellt und ausgetauscht werden, die halt vom Lizenzrecht nicht gedeckt sind. Also das ist schwierig in dem Bereich, wirklich noch zu sagen, das ist hier überhaupt nicht offenkundig. Ich hätte damit überhaupt nicht rechnen müssen, dass ich hier irgendwelche Rechte verletze. Aber man muss eben sich angucken, wer dahinter steckt. Also da ist eine harte Lobby dahinter. Die ist deshalb so hart, weil es um so sehr viel Geld geht. Und man versucht auf sehr vielen Ebenen eben zu unterbinden, diese ganze Tauscherei und Kopieren. Und das ist eine Art natürlich.
Also einfach so sagen, so viel Unsicherheit streuen, dass die Leute sich nicht mehr trauen. Ist die Unterscheidung zwischen Uploadern und Downloadern, wenn so Dinge verfolgt werden? Was genau ist da der Unterschied, der wichtige Juristische?
Ja, juristisch, das hat ja angefangen natürlich mit den Uploadern, also diejenigen, die das zur Verfügung stellen, aber auch die werden verfolgt zivilrechtlich, die sich die Sachen auch runterladen auf dem PC. Also juristisch ist da jetzt kein Unterschied mehr. Das einzige, wo jetzt juristischen Unterschied wäre, wenn ich ohne Lizenz Daten zur Verfügung stelle als Uploader und dafür Geld bekomme.
Aber ich habe das irgendwie so im Ohr, dass gerade irgendwie, wenn es um BitTorrent dann später geht, dass die Leute immer deswegen belangt werden, weil sie etwas hochladen und seltener, weil sie etwas runtergeladen haben.
Ja, der Eingriff, der ist intensiver. Natürlich geht man mehr oder möchte mehr die Leute vom Markt holen, die Uploaden, aber auch diejenigen sind betroffen, die downloaden. Also wenn ich mir das Album von Casper runterlade, dann besteht tatsächlich die Gefahr, dass ich hier auch abgemahnt werde.
Die Unterteilung der Verfolger sagen, wir malen jetzt erstmal nur alle Uploader ab, ist tatsächlich eher willkürlich von den Rechteinhabern, weil es einfacher ist.
Also sie nehmen, was ist einfacher, die Uploader oder die Downloader?
Die Uploader zu verfolgen.
Das weiß ich nicht, was jetzt technisch da einfacher ist, die zu verfolgen. Aber es wurde ja auch rumgebrüllt, dass man die Streamer abmahnen möchte. Also man möchte an alle ran, die mit Daten ihre Freizeit verbringen, etc. ohne Lizenz.
Eigentlich sollen die alle wechseln, sondern nach dem passenden Gesetz gesucht.
Aber es reicht da glaube ich erstmal ein paar Exempel zu statuieren. Muss man aufpassen, dass man da nicht gerade eine arme, alleinerziehende Mutter und irgendwie zwölfjähriges Kind erwischt. Aber ansonsten ist von der GVU die Strategie auch ganz knallhart, diese Fälle dann ganz groß in die Presse zu schleifen, wo irgendjemand dann auch als Konsument einfach große Summen bezahlt hat, um da den abschreckenden Effekt zu erzeugen.
Aber sind wir denn noch bei Exempel statuieren? Also die Zahl, die ich kenne, sind, dass die Verwaltungsgesellschaften pro Monat in Deutschland 300.000 User-IPs sich holen.
Das sind ja die Abmahnanwälte selber, die da hergehen. Das sind ja zwei unterschiedliche Instanzen. Also die GVU ist ja die Front dafür, der Strommann dafür, dass die Leute nicht auf den Musiklabels rumkloppen und die einen schlechten Namen bekommen. Die haben sich zusammengeschlossen. Und die GVU ist jetzt eine Gesellschaft, die das lobbied, die Werbung dafür macht, dass man nicht raubgruppiert und dass man im Knast landet und dass man dort im Knast vergewaltigt wird. Und dass man wieder nach dem Fall... Das waren den Werbespots drin. Also das ist irgendwie von...
Tatsächlich?
Ja, das sind Original-GVU-Werbespots. Da ging so ein kleiner, bleicher Nerd, der dann wieder reingepackt worden ist. Und dann haben sie dann die ganzen anderen Insassen in dem Gefängnis gezeigt, so große, brutale Männer.
Also das ist unfassbar. Man muss richtig, richtig viele Urheberrechtsverletzungen begehen, um dann erst in den Knast zu kommen. Also das dauert eine Weile. Also nicht beim ersten, nicht beim zweiten, nicht beim dritten Vergehen kommt man in den Knast. Das geht nicht so schnell. Das ist harte Werbung.
Die Art und Weise, wie sie dich versuchen, ranzubekommen, ist gerade einfach generell gewerbsmäßiges Hoch- und Runterladen von Dateien, die es unterstellen. Also wenn du an Tauschbörsen teilnimmst von irgendwas, was gerade noch draußen verkauft wird, dann ist es eigentlich erstmal gewerbsmäßig. Und du hast ziemlich einen Ärger, das dann auch vor Gerichte zu schleifen. Das ist so gerade ihre Strategie, mit der sie auch meistens durch die unteren Instanzen in den Gerichten durchkommen.
Ja, da muss ich mich verbessern. Also wenn es um Gewerbsmäßigkeit geht, dann ist das immer eine Qualifizierung. Und da kommt man schnell.
Und die Gewerbsmäßigkeit ist dann wieder Verhandlungssache ab, wann was gewerbsmäßig ist. Da geht es dann anscheinend nicht immer nur darum, ob man Geld dafür nimmt, sondern da geht es manchmal auch darum, ob es jetzt der aktuelle Film ist, der gerade im Kino ist.
Naja, also, dass ich das gewerblich betreibe, also, dass ich das regelmäßig mache, um damit Geld zu verdienen.
Also, das Geld spielt eine Rolle. Solange ich kein Geld dafür nehme, ist es nicht gewerbsmäßig.
Also, sie versuchen es dir erstmal zu unterstellen. Also, das ist auch das, womit sie... Es gibt ja... es gab ja jetzt diese Regelung, dass, wenn du nur Dateien heruntergeladen hast und das nur im kleinen Stil betreibst, dass es dann eine Deckelung der Anwaltskosten gibt. Weil diese ganzen Massenabmahnungen natürlich keine anwaltlichen... kein anwältlicher Aufwand mehr ist. Und das unterlaufen sie eigentlich regelmäßig. Sie setzen doch ihre hohen Anwaltsgebühren an und sagen dann, das ist aber nicht einfach nur privates Kopieren auf den Rechner, sondern das ist schon gewerbsmäßig. Und damit rechtfertigen sie dann gerade noch die hohen Rechtsanwaltsgebühren. Und da muss man dann erst gegenwider vorgehen. Und das ist wahrscheinlich billiger, wenn man keinen eigenen Anwalt bemüht, sondern einfach da Zähneknurschen bezahlt. Und das ist da, wo sie darauf auch spekulieren.
Jetzt ist es auch so, wir waren gerade bei Napster stehen geblieben. Und wenn ich das jetzt so grobe blicke, alles, was danach kam, ist mehr oder weniger, also bis auf die Sharehouse, die wir nochmal extra besprechen müssen, ist das mehr oder weniger peer to peer. Also es gab dann verschiedene Protokolle und Clients, also LimeWire und Knutella und weiß der Geier, Donkey, Soulseeker. Und das endete irgendwann sozusagen in BitTorrent.
Na es gibt da noch eine wichtige Unterscheidung, ob du den Index auch innerhalb deines peer to peer Netzes betreibst, oder ob du nochmal eine zentrale oder dezentrale Instanz hast, um andere Leute zu finden, die auch die Datei, nach der du gerade suchst, zu...
Also der Unterschied zwischen BitTorrent und allen anderen Diensten ist, dass es bei BitTorrent so ist, dass es sozusagen erstmal wissen musst, was du runterlädst und dann ist nur der Download selber sozusagen peer to peer?
Ja, aber es gab auch in anderen Diensten gab es dann einen fertigen Index, wo du dann den E-Donkey Link zum Beispiel bekommen hast, wo du die runterladen möchtest.
Ich würde gerne noch sagen, bevor wir dazu kommen, noch gerne wissen, wann ist denn Napster eigentlich zugemacht worden? Die sind ja sozusagen juristisch aus der Welt geschafft worden, mehr oder weniger, diese ganzen Firmen.
Ich glaube, die wurden gekauft. Napster wurde tatsächlich, die haben einen großen Batzen Geld bekommen und dann gab es irgendjemanden, der sich in den Kopf gesetzt hat, da könnte man doch irgendein Geschäftsmodell daraus machen, aber ich glaube, das Geschäftsmodell war tatsächlich irgendwie, die einfach von der Szene zu kriegen, aufzukaufen und das zu sagen, dass es nicht mehr gibt.
Aber haben die das wirklich mit allen gemacht? Es gab ja verschiedene Anbieter nach demselben Prinzip.
Nein, natürlich ist, da ist halt Geld und einige in der Verwertungsindustrie sind halt auch nicht total bekloppt und haben gesehen, dass wenn man das in großem Stile aufzieht und bequem seinen Usern anbietet, dann haben die da wahrscheinlich auch Lust darauf, Geld auszugeben. Also natürlich kann man offiziell behaupten, die Kids würden eh alle nichts bezahlen wollen, aber just kam ein größerer Forschungsbatzen raus, wo festgestellt wurde, dass Leute einen festen Betrag haben, den sie pro Monat für Musik und Recreational Content ausgeben und der flukruiert nicht groß. Und die meisten wollen auch einfach ihre Musik besitzen und irgendwo Geld dafür hinlegen, soll halt sie nur nicht unnötig beanspruchen und das soll auch nicht in schlechterer Qualität und mit mehr Hesselverboten verbunden sein.
Ja, aber das hört sich jetzt an, als ob wirklich die, das hört sich wirklich an, als ob diese Art von Dateiaustausch sozusagen weggekauft wurde. Da gab es doch aber wahrscheinlich auch Rechtssachen.
Also wenn sozusagen der Kern deine Frage ist, warum gibt's Napster und Nutella und LimeWire und E-Donkey nicht mehr, dann ist der Grund, weil BitTorrent technisch viel besser funktioniert.
Ah, technisch abgelöst, nicht juristisch.
Ja, also die Verwertungsindustrie hat sich eingebildet, man könnte das Problem aus der Welt schaffen, indem man einen Teil davon aufkauft. Das ist natürlich kompletter Unsinn, aber tatsächlich ist es so, dass BitTorrent einfach technisch enorme Vorteile hat und deswegen die anderen Peer-to-Peer-Protokolle abgelöst hat.
Alles klar, dann kommen wir dazu gleich. Wir erklären das ein bisschen genauer, wie es funktioniert und ob das möglicherweise in Zukunft sein konnte. Vorher machen wir aber noch einmal hier im Chaos Radio das FritzInfo mit Nachrichten, Wetter und Verkehr. Heute Chaosradio zum Thema Filesharing. Was ist das und wie funktioniert das so im Laufe der Zeit mit Erdgeist, Bea und Andreas vom CCC. Und wir haben jetzt schon eine kleine Zeitreise gemacht durch die verschiedenen Arten und Weisen, wie man Dateien austauschen kann, falls ihr das verpasst habt. Wir können es jetzt nicht nochmal zusammenfassen, weil dann wäre die Sendung sofort vorbei. Aber es wird natürlich nach der Sendung einen Podcast geben und den könnt ihr euch gerne noch einmal anhören. Wir sprechen jetzt gleich über BitTorrent, also was das macht und wie es funktioniert. Und vorher haben wir noch einen Anrufer, nämlich den Sven aus Berlin. Der benutzt diesen Usenet-Nachfolger Usenext anscheinend. Und hat dazu eine Frage. Hallo Sven.
Morgen. Meine Frage ist folgende. Wie gesagt, Usenext nutze ich nur, bin auch angemeldet und bezahle auch meinen jährlichen Obolus. Meine Frage ist, wie angreifbar bin ich? Weil es werden ja doch Daten von A nach B in größeren Mengen und das bleibt ja nun nicht ungesehen. Sind das normale Daten, die jetzt aufgreifbar sind?
Was meinst du mit angreifbar? Angreifbar im Sinne von hackbar oder angreifbar im Sinne von was kann ein Rechtsanwalt machen, wenn er deine Daten...
Zurückverfolgbar.
Bei welchem Anbieter bist du?
Direkt?
Usenext. Na, Daten fallen auf jeden Fall beim Bezahlen an. Du hinterlässt natürlich deine Datenspur in die Richtung des Anbieters. Auf der anderen Seite musst du wissen, ob du eine verschlüsselte Verbindung zu diesem Server aufbaust. Sprich, ob irgendjemand reingucken kann oder nicht. Und wenn die Daten verschlüsselt sind, dann ist erst mal nicht davon auszugehen, dass jemand zwischen deinem Anbieter, also Usenxt und dir, da reinschauen kann, was du jetzt im Detail runterlädst. Da musst du jetzt aber natürlich dem Anbieter vertrauen. Meistens sind die Anbieter nicht ohne Grund noch nicht von ihrer Juristiktion des entsprechenden Landes kassiert worden. Das kann mehrere Gründe haben. Einer kann sein, dass die dort mit den Organen schon kooperieren und sich dort Informationen sammeln und die dann irgendwann mal später, wenn es opportun ist, die rausholen. Es ist halt eine komplette Vertrauensfrage bei dem Dienstleister, bei dem du dein Geld lässt, was der dann mit den Daten macht, wenn es ihm an den Kragen geht. Kim Schmitz zum Beispiel. Ich würde mich nicht wundern, wenn jetzt sämtliche Kunden bei Megaupload in einer großen Tabelle auftauchen und dann irgendwie bei der Urheberrechtsindustrie diese Tabelle dann im Rahmen eines Deals landet und man dann da belangt wird.
Also alles in allem eigentlich eher Finger weg von lassen, wer weiß was draus wird.
Nicht unbedingt. Du hast da auch irgendwelche Vertragsbedingungen. Du kannst auch mal reingucken, ob es da Informationen gibt, wie mit deinen Daten umgegangen wird.
Das ist die eine Seite zu sagen, das ist ja immer die theoretische Seite. Aber die Frage ist natürlich im Endeffekt immer, wie sehr vertraust du deinem Anbieter? Also der hatte ich in solchen Fällen immer in der Hand.
Und jetzt außer über den Anmeldedaten, die ich dahinter lassen habe, beim Anmelden, beim Bezahlen oder auch über die IP, über die Laufe, weil im Moment glücklicherweise läuft der ganz Spaß noch über Nachbarn. Ganz blöd ist er ja auch nicht. Aber jetzt über die IP, mit der ich jetzt arbeite, ist man da denn zurückverfolgbar oder ist es wirklich klein, gedruckt gelesen und hoffen und beten?
Na, die Logs fallen bei dem Anbieter bei Usenext an. Ich sehe gerade, die haben Handelsregister eintragen, die sitzen in München. Nicht in Russland, wie ich gerade dachte. Ja, die Daten liegen da bei denen. Über die IP-Adresse, über den Zahlvorgang bist du natürlich zurückverfolgbar. Ja, Zweifel ist dann, ob mit irgendeiner anderen Ordnung die IP-Adresse einem Namen zugeordnet wird. Hängt dann immer vom Fall ab, für wie verlässlich diese Informationen gehalten werden und mit welchen Werkzeugen die Daten gesammelt wurden. Aber ich habe gehört, dass es eher doch ziemlich lax gerade passiert. Man geht mit einer IP und einer Uhrzeit zu den Betreibern und sagt, wer warntete. Und die rücken das dann auch raus.
Also, es ist schnell, geht zum Datenübertragen, aber ist auf gar keinen Fall irgendwie anonym oder geschützt. Sven, ich muss jetzt leider abbrechen, weil wir noch Anrufer, noch viel zu besprechen, nicht viel Zeit haben.
Die Info, die ich haben wollte, nicht hören wollte, habe ich gekriegt. Sven, wünsche ich noch einen angenehmen Abend.
So, und dann haben wir noch den Martin aus München.
Hallo.
Du bist es aber nicht von News Next.
Nein, nein, bin ich nicht.
Du hast eine Frage, mach es ganz schnell.
Okay, und zwar, wenn man jetzt MP3s zum Beispiel als Datei betrachtet, sind es ja eigentlich nur lange Zahlen. Und jetzt wollte ich wissen, wo praktisch juristisch der Hemming-Abstand zwischen einer legalen und einer illegalen Datei ist. Der Hemming-Abstand ist praktisch der Abstand zwischen zwei Zahlen, also wieviel sie sich unterscheiden. Und jetzt könnte man zum Beispiel sagen, ich habe ein Bild und ich habe eine MP3-Datei. Das Bild ist jetzt legal bei Wikipedia und die MP3-Datei nicht. Da könnte ich ja die miteinander zum Beispiel verschlüsseln. Und wenn ich jetzt oft genug verschlüsselt, dann ist praktisch sehr viel urheberrechtlich Material, also sehr wenig urheberrechtlich geschütztes Material in sehr viel urheberrechtlich freien Material kodiert.
Das kannst du gerne machen, aber wahrscheinlich wird es niemanden mehr interessieren. Also, was willst du mit so einer... Das ist eigentlich ein Remix und du bleibst damit unterm Radar. Also wie oft in dieser ganzen Filesharing-Geschichte ist es, wenn du irgendwas in einer geschlossenen Benutzergruppe in echt kleinem Kreise machst, juckst du die halt nicht. Und erst wenn du zu groß wirst und wenn du ernstzunehmende Schäden verursacht, dann kommst du da aufs Radar und wenn du jetzt da so ein bisschen juristisch spielst und versuchst so eine Datei noch hin und her zu entkoden, dann ist sie für den Großteil der Benutzer da draußen nicht mehr simpel benutzbar und dann sind sie da auch nicht mehr hinter dir her. Und ansonsten ist, wenn du jetzt direkt auf diese lange Zeichenkette da anspielst und meinst, wie muss man sie verändern, dass es dann irgendwie nicht mehr das Original ist, ist einfach der gesunde Menschenverstand. Also wenn du jemanden zwei Musikstücke vorspielst und dann sagst, naja, ist er dasselbe, dann ist es meistens auch dasselbe. Und so den Richter musst du davon überzeugen, dass es jetzt irgendwie aber ein anderes Lied ist, weil da ein paar Bits drin anders sind, dann guckt er dich schief an und dann hast du ihn da nicht überzeugt.
Ja, aber es ist immer interessant für das eine Zahl, urheberrechtlich geschützt, und das andere nicht. Das könnte ja zufällig ein Lied gleich meiner DNA sein oder ähnliches.
Ja, das will aber keiner hören, für mich.
Und noch zum Thema LAN und FDP, schönes Camp war das letztes Jahr.
Martin, vielen Dank für deinen Anruf. Tschüss. Tschüss. Das ist eine interessante, aber eher theoretische Diskurs, die man in dieser Stelle nicht mehr führen kann. Jetzt haben wir noch eine Viertelstunde, und müssen jetzt BitTorrent und Cherhoster anstarten. Was ich für euch nicht schaffe, deswegen würde ich an dieser Stelle sagen, für BitTorrent verweisen wir auf die Chaosradio Seite. Es gab bestimmt schon mal ein Chaosradio ganz ausführlich, wo das Thema BitTorrent besprochen wurde.
Es gibt auch ein Chaosradio Express, was wir mit dem Tim Brittle abgemacht haben, extra mit den Betreibern vom OpenTracker, von der Instanz, die jetzt auch bei The Pirate Bay lief, und da haben wir das in aller epischer Breite ausgewälzt.
Okay, dann also, wir genügen uns jetzt damit, zu sagen, dass es auch Peer-to-Peer-Datei-Austausch ist.
Aber besser.
Aber besser, und auch mit einem Index, der sozusagen zentral dezentralisiert ist, wenn ich das mal so sagen darf.
Es verdient sich da keiner eine goldene Nase. Also weder The Pirate Bay, noch...
Das ist ein wichtiger Punkt. Damals gab es diese Mailbox mit den Ratios, und dann gab es die von Kim Schmitz, wo er die dicke Kohle eingefahren hat. Und BitTorrent ist irgendwie wie damals mit den Ratios. Jeder lädt etwas ein bisschen hoch, und jeder lädt etwas ein bisschen runter, und dann passt es schon. Und das mit RapidShare und mit Megaupload ist halt eher so, jemand hält die Hand auf und will Geld dafür, dass er das nicht lässt.
Lass uns gleich über die Sharehosters sprechen, ich will nur sagen, man ist schon auch, also Freunde von Freunden sind schon auch so Seiten über den Weg gelaufen, wo diese Torrent-Zuchmaschinen quasi, wo man dann auch irgendwie Kohle zahlen sollte.
Wo der Trog ist, da kommen wir mit den Schweinen.
So sieht es aus.
Aber es funktioniert auch ohne.
Es funktioniert auch ohne. Es wäre mit den Sharehostern ja genauso. Aber da ist es sozusagen verbreitet.
Da musst du ja... Weil die Bandbreite, das ist ja ein ganz entscheidender Unterschied. Bei Peer-to-Peer zahlt jeder seine Anschlussleitung und damit sind die Kosten für die Bandbreite des Hochladens gedeckt. Also jeder hat seine 5 Megabit Upload. Und insgesamt ist es genug, dass er auch alle runterladen kann.
5 Megabit Upload.
Ich habe 10. Ich habe VDSL.
Angeber. Okay, also Sharehostern. Ganz kurz zusammengefasst. Sharehostern funktionieren. Also ganz kurz so, ich lade meine Datei dort hoch bei dem Anbieter. Und jeder, der den Link dorthin kennt, lädt die Datei wieder runter.
Genau, so funktioniert das. Das ist im Prinzip eine Webseite, wo Daten liegen. Und da ist natürlich der Unterschied. Da gibt es den zentralen Server, wo alle runterladen. Das heißt, die Bandbreite fürs Runterladen fällt nicht verteilt über alle Nutzer an, sondern die liegt bei einem, nämlich dem Anbieter. Und der muss das finanzieren. Also braucht man Geschäftsbrüder dafür. Also hält er die Hand auf.
Wie ist das jetzt? Aber die gab es ja relativ lange, diese Sharehostern. Die sind jetzt irgendwie relativ schnell irgendwie am einknicken. Seltsamerweise, obwohl das ja mal alles legal war. Aber wie konnten die sich so lange halten?
Na, die konnten sich deswegen so lange halten, weil die ja ein legitimes Geschäft angeboten haben. Also ich habe eine Seite, da lade ich was hoch. Und wenn dann ein Rechthaber gekommen ist und gesagt hat, da liegt aber was, das gehört mir, haben die gesagt, tut uns leid und haben das gelöscht. Und dass es jetzt Megaupload an den Kragen geht, liegt im Wesentlichen daran, dass da wohl Mails aufgetaucht sind. Also irgendwie sind die Mails des Betreibers von Megaupload der Betreiber in den Händen der Verwertungsindustrie gelandet und deren Rechtsanwälten und die konnten halt anhand dessen nachweisen, dass Megaupload also nicht nur wissentlich in Kauf genommen hat, dass da Sachen hochgeladen werden, wo andere Leute nicht so glücklich damit waren, sondern das sogar gefördert haben. Die haben Leuten Geld dafür bezahlt, dass sie bestimmt Inhalte hochgeladen haben. Und das ist das, weswegen es ihnen gerade an den Kragen geht.
Da hat sich dann ein Gericht in Virginia für zuständig erklärt. Die haben gesagt, also wir haben hier Server, die wurden in unserem Bundesstaat angemietet. Wir haben Leute, die hier aus Virginia dort was runtergeladen haben. Und wir haben hier Leute, die Geld dafür bekommen haben, dass sie was hochgeladen haben. Haben jeweils für diese drei Fälle Personen benennen können. Und hatten dann plötzlich einen Pfeil und haben gesagt, okay, der Schaden ist hier entstanden. Ihr habt ganz eindeutig, auch wenn ihr in Hongkong gemeldet seid, oder die Firma in Hongkong existiert, habt ihr euch an den amerikanischen Markt gewendet. Ihr habt Zahlungen von Amerikanern ganz klar entgegengenommen. Und damit ist es ein Fall hier für unser Gericht. Und wir nehmen die Klage an und haben dann damit um Auslieferung gebeten. Und da Kim Schmitz da in Neuseeland sein Anwesen hatte, respektive noch hat, haben sie sich dann an Neuseeland gewendet und gesagt, hier gegen den liegt bei uns gerade ein Haftbefehl vor. Bringt den mal bitte vorbei. Und in Neuseeland ist das auch strafbar. Und deswegen hat Neuseeland gesagt, machen wir. So ist dann Kim Schmitz dort ins Netz gegangen, hat sich noch in sein Penningroom geflüchtet und wurde dann da rausgeschnitten. Aber jetzt sitzt er da erstmal und wartet dann, also Bailout wird er wahrscheinlich nicht bekommen, und wartet darauf, dass er dann in die Vereinigten Staaten zum Verfahren gebracht wird.
Jetzt ist ja so, normalerweise, wenn so eine Festnahme eines auch irgendwie gearteten Dateiaustauschdienstes stattfindet, ist die Solidarität in der Netzgemeinde relativ groß. Das war ja dieses Mal, lasst es mich diplomatisch von mir, nicht so der Fall.
Na, es ist halt keiner von den Guten. Also er hat halt seit ewig schon durch Freunde verpfeifen, und aus dem, wo man eigentlich versucht, in schöner digitaler Nachbarschaft einfach so datenfreundschaftlich untereinander zu teilen, hat er versucht, seit jeher ohne Rücksichtnahme auf verwandte Geldsäure rauszuschlagen, hat auch ein kleines Ego-Problem, mit dem früher schon bei allen Hackern angeeckt. Und auch der Megauploadservice ist eigentlich nicht im Hacker-Mindset verwurzelt, und deswegen ist es nicht verwunderlich, dass da jetzt ein bisschen Gehässigkeit aus der Hacker-Szene auch entgegenschlägt.
Aber gibt es jetzt sozusagen nur für den Typen, oder auch für diese Art und Weise, wie Dateien ausgetauscht werden, also dieses Share-Hosting, wie es so schön heißt?
Ich denke für beides. Also ich persönlich finde, dass dieses Share-Hosting, wenn jemand daran sich eine goldene Nase verdient, dass das Kids einfach nichts bezahlen wollen, ist für mich Grund falsch. Ich will, dass man teilt, dass man was anbietet, wenn man was bekommt, und das soll nicht Geld sein. Sondern es soll bandbereiter sein und vielleicht eigene coole CC-Musik oder Betriebssysteme, die man da per Bithorn verteilt. Das ist so das Bild, was ich vor Augen habe, wenn ich da an Peer-to-Peer-Technologie hacke.
Generell, gilt es für diese Art von Plattformen? Wie sieht ihr beiden anderen das?
Megaupload ist für mich eindeutig auch die Content-Mafia. So wie die andere Content-Mafia, nur dass der Künstler nicht fast nichts kriegt, sondern gar nichts. Okay, es gibt Ausnahmen. Es ist tatsächlich so, dass es wohl Hip-Hop-Künstler gibt, die auch bei Megaupload Geld verdient haben. Die Sachen hochgeladen haben und dann über den Umsatz, den die Werbung generiert hat beim Download, was verdient haben. Und dies ist tatsächlich ein bisschen schade, die auch daraus für sich als Künstler noch ein Existenzmodell generiert haben. Aber im Großen und Ganzen sehe ich jetzt zwischen einer Time Warner Sony Universal und einem Megaupload keinen strukturellen Unterschied.
Was sagt die Juristin?
Na ja, eine juristische Meinung ist, ich finde, dass das Urheberrecht mittlerweile zu weit geht. Wir sind kulturell darauf angewiesen, dass wir das, was schöpferisch aus einer Gesellschaft herauskommt...
Warte, zum eigentlichen Schlusswort, was ich später komme. Erstmal nur die Share-Hoster, also diese Art und Weise von Dateien austauschen.
Na wenn keine Lizenzen da drauf sind, das ist kein Problem.
Jetzt ist ja so, mit Megaupload relativ viele Share-Hoster, also alle Namen, die ich kenne, außer RapidShare, haben gesagt, wir fahren unsere Dienste mal ein bisschen zurück. Also anscheinend ist denen klar geworden, dass die da nicht ganz viel anders aussehen. RapidShare, wie ist das eigentlich? Stehen die einfach am längsten oder haben die einfach ein Geschäftsmodell, was tatsächlich nicht nur auf diesem Austausch...
Die haben, glaube ich, die beste PR-Agentur. Dass diese Interviews da aufgetaucht sind, das ist so ein Mädel aus der Schweiz, guckt man sich andenkt, irgendwie Klosterinternats-Schülerin. Also so sieht die aus. Also könnte keiner Fliege was zu leide tun, die dann irgendwie darüber redet, dass es doch irgendwie ja bloß um eine Cloud-Dienstleistung geht und irgendwie Cloud-Service sind doch gerade in. Was ja also auch nicht völlig von der Hand zu weisen ist, aber die haben, glaube ich, einfach die beste PR und die besten Anwälte. Nicht so richtig. Also ich meine, natürlich ist das, was Megaupload da getan hat, mit der gezielten Förderung von Leuten, die da interessanten Content hochgeladen haben. Also die haben sozusagen, wenn es irgendwo einen aktuellen Film gab, jemand hat den hochgeladen, haben die Leute Geld dafür bekommen. Und wenn Leute sich den Film runterladen wollten, dann haben die das so eingestellt, dass irgendwie dieser freie Download gerade nicht gereicht hat, um es ruckelfrei zu gucken. Also das war schon sehr darauf optimiert, da aus Content, wo die Verwertungsrechnungen nicht da lagen, Geld zu ziehen, das wussten die auch und das war auch klar. Und natürlich gibt es einen Markt für eine Cloud-Dienstleistung, wo man einfach Dateien hochladen und dann wieder runterladen kann. Das will keiner bestreiten. Und man kann jetzt RapidShare nicht unterstellen, dass die auch so arbeiten. Man müsste eigentlich sagen, dass sie vielleicht nicht so gearbeitet haben. Aber Wissen tut man es nicht. Die wissen wahrscheinlich auch ganz genau, wo ihr Geld herkommt.
Ich glaube, dass es am Ende einfach nur daran lag, dass Kim Schmitz dieses unsägliche Megaupload-Video letztes Jahr gemacht hat. Und irgendwann, du zeigst dir nicht den Stinkefinger, ohne dann...
Dann kam die Geschmackspolizei. Aber wie gesagt, für die unerwünschte Vervielwälterung von Privatkopien sind Cherhos, also scheint es zumindest erstmal weg vom Fenster. Aber anzunehmen, dass damit Filesharing in diesem Raubmordkopie-Sinne aufhört, ist ja wahrscheinlich illusorisch. Was sagt ihr denn, wie wird denn das denn in Zukunft aussehen?
Also P2P hat immer noch eine Chance. Der große Schritt bei BitTorrent ist ja jetzt weg von zentralisierten Trackern hin zu Distributed Hashtables zu gehen.
Das heißt, es gibt...
Ja, naja, ja.
Dieser Magnet-Link, der funktioniert so, dass man...
Halt, ich möchte irgendwie diese zentrale Indizes und sowas... Also pass auf, pass auf. Es muss immer Seiten wie die Pirate Bay geben, wo man sozusagen nachschlägt, was man runterlegt.
Aber inzwischen hatte Pirate Bay auch schon noch dafür Ärger bekommen, dass sie den Tracker und den Index betrieben haben. Und wenn man jetzt Torrents herunterlädt, die so eine ganze Datei beschreiben, dann ist das für die meisten Richter auch schon wieder zu viel.
Und jetzt müssen wir, glaube ich, doch kurz Trecker erklären.
Also es funktioniert so.
20 Leute wollen dieselbe Datei runterladen. Einer hat sie und die anderen laden sich stückweise das runter. Da muss es irgendwo eine zentrale Stelle geben, die weiß, wer gerade die Datei hat und wer daran interessiert ist. So ein sogenannter Trecker. Und das Torrent-Fall, da steht drin, aus was für Stücken so eine Datei besteht. Und das ist natürlich ein zentraler Angriffspunkt, weil der zentrale Vermittler, der sagt, wer mit wem reden muss, um die Dateien zu kriegen, den kann man dann weglagen, beschlagnahmen und so weiter und so fort. Und da gibt es jetzt ein neues technisches Konzept, die Distributed-Test-Table. Da gibt es das nicht mehr, sondern da gibt es nur die große Wolke, wo man dann so eine Frage reinstellt, kennt jemand die Datei? Und dann kommt von irgendwo eine Antwort, ja, ja, ich kenne die Datei, hier sind andere, die die auch haben, weil sie die zentrale Stelle wegfällt, die jemand betreiben muss, die angreifbar ist juristisch. Und das ist sicherlich eine Richtung, in die es noch ein bisschen weitergehen wird, also das vielleicht zusammen mit Anonymisierungsdiensten, wie zum Beispiel Tor, kann man sich also vorstellen, dass das Spiel noch ein bisschen weitergeht, die Dateiaustausch zu erlauben, ohne dass es einen zentralen Angriffspunkt gibt. Und natürlich muss es irgendwo ein zentrales Verzeichnis geben, aber...
Ah nee, das Tolle ist ja, dass so ein Magnet-Link, der passt in Twitter.
Den kannst du in der Twitter-Nachricht tun. Also alles was du wissen musst, ist der Magnet-Link einer Datei. Und das sind halt so 50 Zeichen. Die kannst du im Zweifelsfall auf einen Zettel schreiben. Die kannst du per SMS verschicken. Kannst du einen Twitter-Link tun. Die kannst du im Chat mal eben reinpasten. Und damit fällt der zentrale Punkt weg, wo man das unterdrücken könnte, wo man das blockieren könnte.
Aber das heißt, das heißt, es wird so diese zentralen Suchseiten, wird es auch wahrscheinlich aber trotzdem geben. Werden die dann das nächste Angriffsziel für die Content-Industrie?
Ja, aber da ist irgendwie der... Das ist schon dann schwierig zu konstruieren, wie das angreifbar sein soll. Also wie ist der Magnet-Link noch so? Was ist daran illegal, ist die Frage.
Na, Isohand zum Beispiel hat sich ja in den letzten sechs Jahren ziemlich erfolgreich gegen alle möglichen juristischen Angriffe gewährt, weil sie halt keinen eigenen Tracker betreiben, sondern wirklich nur die Suchseite. Und ist so ein kleines Familienunternehmen, machen da halt nicht viel Geld damit, aber haben einen Auskommen und haben dort schon recht erfolgreich argumentiert, dass sie nicht Dateien zur Verfügung stellen, sondern nur Beschreibung von Dateien. Und damit haben sie sich bisher rauswinden können aus juristischen Gemetzeln. Und das funktioniert da schon noch ganz gut. Also das ist schon noch vor der letzten Verteidigungslinie, weil da kann man noch Torrents runterladen. Und wenn Isohand wirklich irgendwann fallen sollte, dann wird es halt andere Wege geben. Sowas findet man halt auch in Google. Also dann wäre dann Google die Suchmaschine der Wahl, mit der man Magnetlinks findet.
Das heißt aber sozusagen, unter der derzeitigen Rechtsprechung, es gibt aber wahrscheinlich doch schon Versuche, dass man das vielleicht noch verschärfen kann. Habt ihr da noch was? So wie es gerade beschreibt, ist der Krieg zwischen Contentindustrie und Filesharern vorbei?
Ja, er ist natürlich nicht vorbei. Die Contentindustrie fährt ja gerade auf Super, Pippa, Akta und lauter andere vierbuchstabige Abkürzungen. Die schaffen wir, glaube ich, auch in den nächsten fünf Minuten nicht mehr zu erklären.
Nehmen.
Aber es läuft darauf hinaus, dass sie gerne das Recht hätten, irgendwie alles abzuhören und alles abzuschalten, was ihnen in den Kram passt. Also die Bandagen werden härter.
Na, jetzt sind es halt keine kinderpornografischen Bilder mehr, sondern jetzt ist es, in den Vereinigten Staaten war es dann halt, die Urheberrechtsindustrie, die da hergegangen ist, wollte das mit dem SOPA sich da mal ins Gesetz lobinen. Und dann haben sie mal ganz kurz einen Shitstorm aus dem Internet erfahren. Also, du weißt, dass du verloren hast, wenn Google seine Seite wegen dir schwärzt. Und damit war dann erst mal SOPA fürs erste Ad acta gelegt. Und ich weiß nicht, ob das nicht ein Schuss in den Fuß gewesen ist, weil jetzt mal sich Leute damit ernsthaft damit auseinandersetzen, um zu gucken, wie groß ist denn diese Industrie eigentlich, die da grad wadenbeißt und lobbied und wie wichtig ist die. Und wenn da Google daher kommt, wenn Wikipedia daher kommt und so einen Terz macht, wie stehen die dazu eigentlich im Vergleich zur Bedeutung für die Gesellschaft? Das hat Obama gestern in seiner, vorgestern an seiner State of the Union, noch mal gesagt, dass er einen besonderen Wert darauf legt, dass auch Urheberrechte im Ausland gerade wahrgenommen werden und sie dort versuchen, alles Mögliche dafür zu tun. Aber ich glaube, dass da schon Sie verstanden haben, dass man das Netz nicht kaputt zensiert, um der Urheberrechtsindustrie das Wort zu reden.
Na, schauen wir mal, ob das klappt. Man kann da ja noch skeptisch sein. Das war auf jeden Fall das Chaosradio 175. Eine kleine Geschichte des Filesharing, das es wahrscheinlich weiterhin geben wird. Keine große Überraschung, aber wir wissen jetzt zumindest, wie es angefangen hat und möglicherweise auch, wie es weitergehen wird. Und da werden Magneten anscheinend eine große Rolle spielen. Erdgeist, Andreas und Bea, vielen Dank fürs hier sein.
Euch einen schönen Abend.
Und wenn man genaueres wissen will über den Chaos Computer Club, kann man jeden Donnerstag bei euch vorbeikommen, richtig?
So ist das.
Die Bea haben wir einfach mitgenommen. Die ist hier vorbeigekommen, jetzt zum zweiten Mal. Schwupps haben wir so eingepackt.
Und Schwupps habe ich eine Menge gelernt.
Einfach verhaftet und dann direkt ins Radio, verrückt. Hier in dem Radio drin gibt es nach dem Chaos Radio Henrik Schröder mit dem Night Flight und Punk-Musik. Dabei wünsche ich viel Spaß. Den Podcast dieser Sendung erscheint in wenigen Stunden schon auf RitzC und später noch auf ChaosRadio.de. Dabei viel Spaß. Mir bleibt nur noch eins zu sagen. Lasst euch nicht überwachen und macht immer schön eure Backups.